Are we starting now?
Yeah.
Well,
I was going to fucking tweet it.
Oh,
there we go.
The Joe Rogan experience is sponsored by fleshlight.
They're number one sex toy for my niche.
If you go to Joe Rogan's website,
click on that link on the right side and put the code Rogan in to save yourself.
How much Joe?
15% off ride.
It's the number went sex toy for a reason.
Because when you fuck it,
it feels way better than any product you can buy.
It's try.
I have tested every single thing out.
It's a of central Japanese toys,
place things made an Africa out of cantaloupes.
I mean,
I've tested Cameroon in Africa.
It's produce based sex toys mostly in this statement in the the South Africa
regions.
Uh,
but there's flashlights always in the number one.
It's the best.
They really,
it's a genius invention.
I mean,
it's,
it doesn't get the credit that it deserves because everybody's so embarrassed
with dirty a fucking song.
But it's an amazing product.
I mean,
as far as like really effective products,
oh,
I mean,
it's really does what?
As advertised.
It feels like a great vagina,
not just a good vagina,
a great vagina.
And if you,
if you like soaking in warm water before you fuck it.
Oh yeah.
It feels like a human body expands.
No.
Warms the human body.
Does it make it feels like a human body.
I did one of those sleeps here today where you wake up and you're just
completely like,
oh,
I don't have to do anything.
So I'm just going to lay here and just kind of stretch out a little.
And then I saw the flashlight on my nightstand,
like,
oh,
I'm ready to go deep with this shit.
It just clean.
It had never been used before.
It was one of these new ones.
And I got this lotion.
It was every time I come,
I think I'll just do it in the morning,
then I'll go back to bed.
Uh,
talk for some reason that morning not fills me with energy.
Yeah.
Then I'm like that time to start the day that p Boehner where you,
you actually bypassed the p and still comic or even go pee.
That's amazing.
That's a,
that's a talent right there.
Those nighttime boners are so important to hotel rooms to go to bed beat off
right before you go to bed,
like in the hotel room.
Sometimes when you're on the road,
you know you have a hard time sleeping.
That's when those nighttime masturbation,
my worst times when I'm on the road,
flashlight will come in handy and I know I'm gonna hold a seat for two hours.
I'd have to go to radio and I'd like to beat off into a sock,
but I don't,
I want a hot,
I want to reuse that sock just for morning radio.
I don't want to use a fresh soc for it right on the word.
You can't bring the flashlight with you though.
That's like the lineup.
Something about travel.
It's like,
wow man.
You're just,
you know,
you're admitting that you can't even go wherever we're a couple of days without
beating off like such a blatant admission.
Just committing to it so much so that you're,
you're not worried about being stopped at the airport and search for sex toys.
They should have a travel flashlight.
Dude.
You don't even know what happened.
You Know Veronica Ricci,
she,
uh,
she went to
Israel,
uh,
last week I went there by herself and they thought she was a spy and so they
went through it,
her luggage for like four days and they shouldn't have luggage for four days.
And they were like asking her,
because I guess they thought she was like a,
like a terrorist of some sort because there's no other like girls her age,
you know,
that they are not Jewish is visiting Israel right now I guess.
And so she got like,
she had to buy a whole all know she had to buy all new clothes and then she said
it was like pretty fucking dirty and scare you could,
there's people with machine guns everywhere.
A lot of people played elbows and she's like,
dude,
when you see the machine guns and oboes getting played everywhere.
So just because she came there by herself,
they thought that she was a terrorist,
searching everybody
and,
and well she also bought her ticket like,
you know,
last minute.
Like she just wanted to go to,
let's get through these commercials.
So we could talk about this.
We have to send his commercials for us down.
So if bring your flashlight to Israel,
be careful.
But other than that,
go nuts.
Well,
we're also sponsored by onnit.com it's o,
n,
I,
t,
makers of Alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune and new mood.
What are these?
Most of them are what's called nootropics.
And what nootropics are,
is their supplements that are designed to enhance the way your brain functions.
It's a very controversial issue.
So Google it,
check it out.
I've been using new tropics long since long before I ever started hawking.
Um,
I was uh,
using bill Roman ask you stuff called neuro one.
That's when I first got introduced to the world of nootropics and I've had very
good results with them.
I like them,
but I believe in all kinds of vitamins.
I believe he eat unhealthy too.
He's stinky bitches.
Go to [inaudible] dot com check it out.
The supplements,
all of them.
When you order 30 pills,
there was at 100% money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the product.
You just have to say,
this sucks.
Nobody is trying to rip you off.
Everything that we sell is the highest quality possible,
the highest quality available,
and the best measures that we know and the of the,
the most important thing for us is that no one feels like they got ripped off.
So we make sure that there's a 100% money back guarantee on all first orders
through that.
Yeah.
People tell you that.
They get their money back.
You know,
it's some people,
first of all,
I don't know how everybody's body works.
Everybody's body works different.
I could never claim that something that's effective for me is effective for you.
There's some things that other people are allergic to that I'm not.
There's a lot of weirdness when it comes to bodies.
Yeah.
I don't know how your brain works.
Maybe your brain works better than mine all the time anyway.
You know,
maybe some people need nootropics and some people are like those kids that can
look out a window of an airplane and then draw everything they saw and exact
proportion.
Interesting.
That kid,
that kid do that.
I don't know.
Maybe his brain is just working like in that function in that regard,
like so much higher rpms and mind can ever achieve ever.
I don't know.
But I from me,
nootropics are effective.
They are for a,
a lot of my friends that take him a mayhem believes in him.
He told me the first time I ever gave him to them,
he goes,
I knew it was legit when I was fucking people up in video games.
He goes,
my video game synapses would just stop fire.
Really?
Yeah,
because you're,
you're minus his video games are fucking,
there's a lot of shit going on in your brain.
Like people think that video games or vegging out bullshit.
Military Training.
Yeah.
It's when you're playing a really intense game of counterstrike or something
like that.
You know,
I never got into that game,
but because I was really more one on one games,
but there was a lot of dudes who would play counterstrike and these
motherfuckers were like literally virtually going to war that have a land
together and then I'll be screaming out instructions at each other and they all
had headphones on and they'd be playing.
Some dudes on the other side of the room,
they were at war.
There was a lot of shit going on.
They had that.
They had that kid who got a concussion in football and then killed himself like
a day later.
I said he shouldn't have done anything that would stimulate the brain too much,
but he's playing video games all day and they're like,
absolutely.
Do not do that.
Oh my God.
Your video games and concerts like you need to rest your brain for a little
while.
Yeah.
Video Games are really intensely and it like intensely exciting for the brain
and about a lot of weird areas,
you know?
I mean they get you like you're really at boards,
digital wars going on,
you know,
especially the live one on one internet battles.
When I first found out that you could,
you could actually play a game with someone live on the Internet.
I thought that was the coolest fucking thing I've ever heard of.
The first I didn't know anything about pains.
So the first time I did it I'd like get logged on to servers and like Sweden and
was like,
yeah,
I want to play some guy from fucking Sweden.
Sweden.
Yeah.
But it's pretty cool.
Huge lag time.
Like your people are disappearing in front of you.
You're shooting rockets.
Like you're not getting all the packets from the game because they're so far
away.
So you would have like a big ping time to them.
We had,
we had Ethan that in college,
it's everyone's connected to carmageddon.
Ooh.
Inbetween levels.
Like whoever won that race,
whatever,
we'd all just pour out into the halls and start like mocking each other for
like,
while they were loading up the next level.
It was super fun.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
There's nothing like what,
what video games can do like as far as like,
like that sort of a sense of a team game.
Almost like a team chess match.
There's nothing like video games.
I mean chess is a brilliant game.
It's an amazing game for,
for like 25 straight hours playing video games.
Yeah.
You don't get tired.
You want to keep going.
It's higher to 2:00 AM 8:00 AM you wait,
you get away from the game and your hands are shaking.
Your whole body is pulsating with adrenaline.
Yeah.
Dude.
We used to have these ones,
these quake lan matches what we would all get together and we would like have
death matches where like we would uh,
either have team matches where it'd be our team and we'd go against other teams.
That was always real fun.
Or we would just fuck each other up.
We would just have melees where anybody was against everybody.
We just run into a room and everybody fucking kill everybody until there's one
last man standing.
We should talk about this on the podcast.
We should know.
God dammit.
It is.
And it isn't.
Have you ever heard the most people will get this part right?
Yeah.
We have to make our commercials really?
Commercials.
Yeah.
Eventually I have to shorten these notes because this big,
because this stuff doesn't get put on.
I don't think Sirius radio.
I know.
You know what I mean?
On a.com you know what to do,
but really just entering the code name.
Rogan save 10% all right.
Cue The music.
Joe Rogan experience Joe Rogan podcast.
My night all day.
What did you do that when you slow it by half?
Crafty Devil.
It's Dj Red Van
Arch fears of the house.
We've been talking for like 10 15 minutes about how fucking awesome video games
can be and so the serious stuff starts right now.
Yes.
Yeah.
Wow.
Sort of.
Yeah.
That's a lot to do it whenever they want.
It really should just record the commercials.
Maybe I'm they maybe not.
People like it like this.
Yeah.
Some people don't.
You know,
it gives people a reason to listen.
Yeah.
It's a conversation more than anything,
you know?
Yeah,
I dunno.
I think it's more effective.
I've been listening to us on Sirius radio so much lately.
Yeah,
it changes my whole look of how we,
I did this part of the podcast.
I think it's seems really legit when you're just driving around and you just
flip a radio station and you're like,
what the fuck?
That's me.
Hear you.
So yeah,
it is radio.
It's still is like wow.
It's still theirs.
Yeah.
Well it's also with the idea of the radio is it's people that don't necessarily
want to hear you,
so you want to be like a little better for them.
You know the beans with the people that are already like you,
like your podcast fans,
you already got them.
But if you're on serious and you know when they click on and you're stumbling
through your words and sound like a retard,
like what?
Who is this?
Yeah,
what the fuck?
The fear factor guy has a radio show.
He's saying I'm too much,
but he's saying,
you know every other thing,
you know,
I fucking hate that.
I say,
you know the ones that catch about your Sam,
I've been watching that lately.
You know what,
I watched a MC,
Chris was on your podcast.
Very Nice Guy,
Mc Chris.
And this is not a criticism of him,
but it made me realize about myself that he says,
you know a lot.
And I'm like,
God damn bitch.
You do too.
That's what I said to myself.
I'm like,
you say,
you know all the time,
you know,
when you see that somebody else who can see it in yourself,
it's like a,
it's like a trickery for um,
you know,
you're,
you're pretending you're saying,
um,
but you're saying it with two words.
You know what,
that's not,
no,
no.
It's not,
you know,
fuck it.
I'm,
what do I say a lot you say,
you know,
to a lot of us do.
It's,
I think it's,
um,
I think it's one of those things that one of the one,
one of us starts doing it.
Then we all just saw,
everyone just starts killing argued on the worst thing I say a lot.
I think like maybe yes,
you are a big like,
yes.
You say like a lot,
a lot of girls say like a lot because that's my way of saying like,
here I'll give you a different,
um,
yeah,
well it's good when it works.
That is what you say.
But if it's just like,
you know this like,
so I'm like,
and he's like,
and there's like,
I'm like,
are you serious?
Like is this like,
I'm sure like Whoa,
like,
you know what I mean?
I'm like,
I don't get it in our feet in the future.
Somehow we're not doc talk and we're going to have her phone talk for us.
You said something really interesting the other day that I've been really
thinking of when it was a very valid point.
You were saying that that's what autism is.
That's what people that are emotionless and that's what it's eventually
digitally,
there really won't be a need for emotions anymore and it's like that might be
the next stage.
You know,
a lot of people speculated that what some of the autism spectrum disorders are,
is the human body possibly making a change possibly for some new development.
I don't know.
It could be a lot of different things.
I mean,
they say there's environmental factors like look,
like a lot of people say that it's toxins.
There's been arguments about vaccinations and all sorts of different things.
And,
but the idea is that they don't know what it is or maybe it's that it's just
being diagnosed more.
There's arguments both ways,
but something's happening and there's a lot of kids that are experiencing this
sort of a disassociated behavior,
you know?
And uh,
it's,
it's super unfortunate,
but it might be representing according to people way smarter than me.
So I don't even know exactly what they're meaning by this.
Yeah.
But they're saying that it might be representing a next stage of human beings
and that as a result of all of our,
like technological connection with each other and you know,
being,
being able to text and send pictures and do everything sort of virtually to each
other,
that slowly the human body is having less and less of a need of the extreme sort
of emotional interaction that has sort of gotten us to where we are today.
I got addicted to the,
to the computer and the phone.
Yeah.
It's like it takes me two hours to go,
just start taking a shower cause I didn't want me to talk to this again.
And the Facebook and then Twitter.
It's something unhealthy.
There's something going on with it.
There's something fascinating about it is just like what we were talking about
earlier about video games that we were saying that video games are so
stimulated.
Like you never get tired of just the light is that a lot of it maybe great.
Then the visuals,
really cool graphics.
It's the challenge and people that want to be a challenge.
It's like,
again,
it's like anything,
well it's also replacing all that,
those instincts that are in our DNA that sort of got us to where we are today.
You know,
I've been watching this.
It's still,
what's that?
Sit still and just look at things.
Yeah.
Move your wrist.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean that's replacing going out and killing animals.
That's replacing,
fighting off the enemy that's replacing,
you know,
swimming to safety.
Cause your boat breaks a hole in it.
You know what I mean?
I mean this is the world that we're living in there.
It's not filled with all these needs for violent explosions and running away
from danger and all the shit bodies program for.
So instead it's,
it's slowly entering to some sort of a symbiotic relationship with machines.
And as it enters into this relationship with the machines,
it becomes less and less emotional.
It's less and less interactive with humans.
Less and less dependent on that.
And perhaps one day ultimately not dependent at all because one day ultimately
if you expand on how far,
how much of a connection we have with computers now and how this didn't even
exist at all just a hundred years ago,
no electronics,
no nothing a hundred years ago.
Think of it.
It's not outside the realm of possibility to envision some sort of a permanent
and direction that humans are going to have with some sort of electronic and
mark clause that would come out to hold your phone when you're typing on it.
Something where you know you're much more interactive virtually than you ever
are physically and that you will eventually become a part of a fucking system.
Like you will,
you'll become an emotional wreck.
Hard integrated or Yup.
A Borg for real nuts.
Right.
Super Possible.
It sounds like a way more evolved.
Well,
you gotta think,
I mean,
we're hanging onto these goddamn emotions,
these things that make us fly planes into buildings and these things that make
us want to,
you know,
Jack other people,
and I was reading CNN today and I'm that guy in,
uh,
I believe it's Liberia.
There's just one of them got convicted,
sent a message to the other tyrants.
I ain't gonna send shipper a message.
Yeah.
How has that autonomy or even close to getting overthrown?
You've already done enough shit to get tried for.
Yeah.
I never even heard of this.
Charles Taylor.
He's one of the more amazing,
it just didn't have a good name.
That was his only problem.
I'm not amazing.
Yup.
He snuck through being Charles Taylor and just,
just fuck that country.
That's up Liberia,
civil war for years.
What did he do?
What was his exact crime?
I don't know.
Probably killing people because
I dunno,
probably Chile.
Maybe.
Jay walked back and forth like a billion times in a row.
What was his name?
Charles Taylor.
Uh,
my friend Justin,
I have a few friends from there,
from Liberia,
from college.
They were just like talking.
It just ruined everything.
The infrastructure was just ruined by the civil war,
the whole,
the whole story of Liberia.
So crazy.
And we've mentioned this before,
but if you haven't heard the episode,
please go and check out vice guide to Liberia.
You want to see what's up in Liberia?
Holy Shit.
Was that fascinating?
They went,
yeah,
he went.
Shane went,
but trying to get tourism back.
Oh my God,
dude,
you got to see this guy's video vice guide to Liberia is one of the best pieces
of online journalism I've ever seen ever.
They went into Liberia,
they explained everything.
They showed like these,
these like brothels where it's like a dollar or something like that,
or 25 cents and was something ridiculous,
you know?
I mean it shows how scary it is there.
And they got talked to that general butt naked guy.
The guy who was telling them about how they would kill the,
the enemy's babies and eat their flesh is telling him this.
I mean,
he's talking about how we would kill the flesh and eat the flesh of the innocent
child and that that would make us invincible.
And he would fight naked.
And he called them general button naked cause he would go to war naked.
He would shoot people or as naked.
Yeah.
He's responsible for the deaths of thousands and thousands of people personally.
Absolutely responsible.
And he became a Christian.
And when he became a Christian,
they forgave him.
But yes,
he's a preacher and they forgave him for all those words because he found the
Lord.
Wow.
The Christianity.
It's a crazy story.
I mean,
if you're sorry for it.
Yeah.
But I mean the fact that he was able to kill and eat babies and they don't want
him in jail.
Yeah.
He would kill and eat innocent children cause he had a change of heart soon
enough.
Yeah.
He found the Lord.
Wow.
You know,
that's uh,
well it was just a rehab and he's already rehab.
Yeah.
I guess he's,
he's out.
He's good.
He feels bad before it's totally bad for you or whatever.
Like I don't think he was because he was hungry.
You only did it because he wanted to be invincible and need to do to be
invincible.
You had to do something unbelievably heinous.
And in times of war you had to be willing to eat.
You'd get like their energy,
I dunno.
Well,
you're committing so far to terror and horror,
you would probably be,
I mean,
the preserve occur mentality that they must've had to be able to do that to
innocent children.
I mean,
it's just to be completely inhuman like that.
And then the fact that this guy,
all he has to do is I'm just learn about some old stuff and learn about Jesus
and find the word of God and where everyone's like,
all right,
we're gonna.
We're gonna let you go.
Do
I know you feel bad.
You're a priest now.
I mean,
what are you,
that is a crazy place to live because one of it's pretty static kind of text or
it can,
oh yeah,
he can fuck.
Okay.
Most priests are allowed,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
Half and half.
No,
most pretty sorry.
I think,
right.
Or not allowed.
Yeah.
That's,
I mean,
that's what it is.
And um,
in Catholicism it's nothing.
Catholicism.
I noticed the war.
Yeah.
Catholicism.
It's nothing,
you know,
a lot of fuck anybody.
No,
no fucking done period.
But I think that's the only one that requires you to be completely celebrate,
right?
Oh yeah.
Other ones just to have to be married.
Well,
monks,
monks aren't like right back Buddhist monks are,
no,
that's supposed to fuck that.
That makes sense.
So they'll go without talking to her.
They had this,
um,
uh,
interview with the Dalai Lama recently.
It's funny that everybody's like,
listen to this dude.
It was,
it was a real weird thing.
He's like,
you know,
they asked him about women.
It was like,
Yo,
there's,
sometimes I'm attracted to women,
but I think,
oh,
it's so much work and I can't do this Dalai Lama that.
Yeah.
I love his Twitter.
I always check it as it goes.
Yeah.
He's,
he really is a cool guy,
I think.
Really?
Yeah.
That's cool.
I think so.
He's all positive.
It's funny,
Lama,
his,
I mean,
his argument about,
uh,
being a relationship,
she's like,
Huh,
I can't,
it's too much trouble.
It's not trail off at ease.
I mean it is.
He's writing a lot of ways.
So he has sex though.
He would go have a relationship.
I don't think he has it ever has.
I think that's who's a title Mama.
Where did he come from?
Sea as he was born.
The Dalai Lama.
Oh yeah.
It was one of,
it's one of those things where you're sort of a,
I can't think he's like the 16th or something like that.
It's what it is,
is beyond ridiculous.
It's not just a dude.
I was thinking of the Gandhi.
Is it dude?
It's been like,
Oh God.
He's a completely different guy.
Yes.
Oh,
they should have met though.
I know
they did.
Do we know if they didn't?
I wish they did,
but it looks like he's old enough to known Gandy.
How old was gone?
It,
there's a lot of Dalai Lama's.
Then there was some bidding at one when he was around.
I'm sure there was Gandhi around forties,
50s,
60s.
I'm in the 19 hundreds of thing.
Do you see Adam?
Uh,
Jimmy came Oco.
I did that presidents.
Uh,
yeah.
What did he exactly say?
Can you pull it up?
Oh,
did,
that was the word about the big marijuana he did.
Oh yeah.
That's so good.
He started if he was okay,
he started strong and I'm going a little slow for a while and then by the time
we got to the marijuana I was like tuned out already.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I was like,
I think there's just skirting over my head and then he ended up strong.
No,
he,
it was just an uncomfortable situation.
You asked like how many people here have not smoked pot?
Yeah.
And then like maybe a quarter of the crowd raise our hand and then I think he
made his point from there.
Yeah.
It's play the shit out of it.
Beautiful.
Now this is the whole thing.
Yeah,
I know.
I can find it.
Oh,
I bet you can hear a fucking animal wants you find it.
Not only for a sentence,
the,
it was the jackass.
Which no offense sir,
but I think you got the wrong lesson.
I think you met Allen.
This is the boring person that was already these guys lined with a perfect body.
George Clooney,
just members of the media,
politicians,
corporate executives,
advertisers,
lobbyists and celebrities.
Everything that is wrong with America is here in this
from tonight.
Unfortunately,
the speaker of the house,
John Bain,
was on my class,
I think from last year.
Nancy Pelosi believes in lipstick the same way she believes in government.
Too much is never enough.
Jake tapper.
That's how he was discovered.
Some people say Mitt Romney will be elected president because he's
secondly,
we're really smart,
but what are you doing?
Bryan?
Five is off.
Then I'm going to play a little bit,
right
any end.
Rick Santorum may not have won the nomination,
but he succeeded in getting his message out,
not just to Americans but to people all a flat the world.
Paul is still in there.
He's still sticking with it to me.
Ron Paul looks like the guy who gets unloaded hooded at the end of every Scooby
doo epics.
It's great to see the Gingrich's here tonight because I guess that means the
check cleared.
Oh Shit.
Nude.
I have a question.
How can you be against gay marriage when you yourself are the son of two gay
parents,
the Michelin man and the stay puft marshmallow man stumble a marshmallow.
I don't understand politicians who are against gay marriage.
I don't understand anyone is against gay marriage and where when you really
think about it,
aren't all marriages kind of gay?
I mean,
hello
as a man when you get married,
essentially what you're saying is I will never touch another woman as long as I
live now.
Let's put jewelry on each other and dance.
Not that it's any of my business,
Mr Gingrich,
but why are you waiting until Tuesday to drop out of this?
Just do it now.
It's,
oh,
it's time to meet or get off.
The Pot.
Electoral process has changed a lot over the last 10 years.
As you know,
the president of finally gave in and
of Guardian and hit one of those big boxes of all the different kinds of chips
we can get to the pot part.
Super committed.
Super Committees are two committees.
What super cuts is to cuts the TV in 2000 and list of Madison.
Let's take a quick poll is so good at this is your hand if you've never smoked
pot.
Brit Hume,
he's high riding now
he's on his fourth almond macaroon.
Mr President,
I hope you don't think I'm out of line here,
but marijuana is something that real people care about and the fact that you
believe Speaker Baner when he tells you he's still has control of his party,
leads me to believe that you must be smoking some crazy great weed yourself.
Okay.
Woody Harrelson just woke up.
As we know now,
last year at this dinner,
President Obama had his team on the way to kill Osama bin Laden it.
Yeah.
He's so good at that,
man.
That guy is a,
he's in my opinion,
I think he's the best talk show host alive.
Yeah,
it's pretty fun.
He's the best at like weaving between ninth is sort of a subtle,
you know,
he's fucking around like way of talking with like being like a very,
very professional expressive and Alex or it's like he's so good at it man.
I think he's got a few times to watch cause fire guys a warm up so it'll stand
like a thought.
I don't think he gets the credit he deserves.
I think Jimmy Kim was the best talk show host in the country and the other one's
all done right.
Well except I still love Letterman cause he's just,
to me Letterman is just,
he's a staple.
I'll,
I'll watch those things cause we grew up interview that.
He'll do,
you know,
once a year.
I just,
I've,
I've always just the guy he's sold,
he's got so much histories.
I mean Letterman is so good.
He's so quick.
Yeah.
Spin around for so long.
And I think Jon Stewart too.
I don't watch Jon Stewart is it's so committed to politics and that that
political shit.
I don't,
I don't watch it as much.
Maybe as I would if it was a,
just a,
like if Jon Stewart had his own show instead of just the daily show,
but I think he's also one of the past matter goes on it all the time now.
Yeah.
I'll magical.
It's like one of the,
um,
what did,
what did they have him?
Whatever correspondence.
How magical is this shit?
He's such a great guy.
Yeah.
That uh,
that guy's the best til easily.
I mean,
I think he's the best at political stuff that cove the shore.
That fucking tastes great until he does.
It's like,
how does it keep this character?
To me,
it keeps it going to take the opposite approach.
Smart opposite side.
In order to mark that opposite side.
He must be smart as fuck.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
Yes.
You're talking about the airplanes landing in Israel.
What's that?
We're talking about his wife couldn't pull over in Israel.
Oh,
Brian's girl.
You said wife,
you just get the shit out of me.
What'd you do?
I got married.
Oh Dude,
you,
I'm your girl that you were seeing,
right?
Uh,
went to Israel by herself,
you were saying?
Yeah,
she decided she wanted to,
she does that.
She likes to travel.
So she'll,
she wanted to go do a yoga yoga retreat in Israel,
which is one of these places that you go to just relax and it's kind of like a,
yeah,
but it's a place you've lit.
Can live there also.
Tivity help out there.
It's like a real,
like,
I guess I'd temperature Wheelock.
Right.
What's it called?
Rancho relaxo.
Something like that.
I forget the name of it.
Some Jewish names.
You don't have to relax off from that one.
Okay.
What George?
Although with the mud and not a lot,
but that's,
see,
yeah.
What's it called?
But see,
no,
it's like some kinds of company that's there.
I don't know.
She goes see Israel and yoga retreat and,
and so because you bought her ticket last second and uh,
because she was going by herself,
I guess she,
you know,
she's not Jewish.
And I guess it's at a time of war kind of.
It's kind of worry right now.
And like,
so they took her luggage for like three or four days and uh,
she had to buy all new clothes and they thought she wears,
you know,
got questioned up and down,
you know.
And uh,
I guess they really thought that she was some kind of like,
you know,
terrorist thing.
There was a girl who was a Jewish photographer when she was over in Israel and
she was taking pictures and they leave.
What's no of a artwork like a Palestinian graffiti.
And uh,
since she had a photo of it on her laptop,
the guys at the Israel,
the tea has their version of Tsa.
They shot her laptop,
the shot it,
they fucking shot it and they gave it back to her.
They blew a hole through it.
Yeah.
Can I think,
just take out the hard drive and go,
all right,
here's your laptop back.
Where did they shoot?
They shot it in the back.
She heard a bang and then the guy comes out and gives her a laptop and it's got
a bullet hole on it.
It's crazy.
It's just,
I think he's trying to let her know,
like you,
you don't,
I don't think he knew that she was a journalist.
I think she probably thought she was someone that was seeing this and she was
taking pictures of it,
like she thought it was funny or cool or whatever for whatever disrespectful
reason.
This chick had it on her laptop and his eyes and he was like,
oh,
really?
Yeah,
you let you like looking at that and you're like looking at someone talking shit
about us,
so he fucking,
so he'd just run down a hall,
pass on graffiti and shot it.
No,
he checked all her stuff and as he's checking her laptop,
he went through all of her photographs and as he's going through her
photographs,
he saw this antisemetic graffiti that she had photographs of,
so he closes it,
pushes it aside and fucking shoots it.
Wow.
Yeah,
pretty intense.
I just know how to shoot.
She travels though.
I know that she probably had at least 20 to 30 different vibrators or dildos are
sex toys in there,
so I wonder if that they thought all that shit with some kind of weapon,
so I could just imagine all these Jewish guys like with these big vibrators.
It's like,
I think it's okay.
Yeah.
At least they searched everybody.
There is such a massive difference between Jews in America,
Jews in Israel,
there's really no one's there to
consider because of the aesthetics.
She said she went right to the beach and it was just dirty and scary and then
she went to,
Oh,
a couple of the places that,
and it was just really freaky because there was people who are walking around
with machine guns and then she said there was a lot of gay people and one of the
cities,
because I guess that's just new thing there,
that new thing.
Gay people go there visit gigantic.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's where she landed television.
I think so.
Yeah.
The beaches are not dangerous by the way.
The army people don't know all the time.
It takes some time ago.
He was telling.
How long did you live in Israel for?
Two years.
Two and a half years.
That's crazy.
What was it like for you?
It was great.
It's such a beautiful country and Jerusalem is all built out of stone,
pretty much down the old Jerusalem and everywhere.
It's just like,
yeah,
things are great.
Everybody sort of knows each other a little bit.
Not like completely,
but they're all,
I mean until recently you could hitchhike everywhere really in between places
and you just tell him completely different now though,
right?
Yeah,
the intifadas change the tanks,
but the uprising,
the Palestinian uprising,
that's what they call it.
The end of file [inaudible] so yeah,
Wow.
What is the issue giving up land?
What's the actual issue?
Actual issues Palestinians started in,
their chief tenant was,
we want to drive the Israelis into the sea and they're never going to give up on
that.
How was in their books?
That's what they wanted.
They will never rest until all the Israelis are driven into the oceans that says
they want.
So in the meantime you have to figure out a way to like appease enough of them
to give them the right amount of land and let the other ones not
keep going to war with us with them.
So when you say that that's in,
it's in their book,
is that like in one of the religious books?
No,
the PLO when they started that was one of the Palestinian Liberation
Organization and that was linked a lot of terrorist shit in the 1970s right?
Wasn't that the Munich Munich articles?
Yeah,
the uh,
the killings at the,
at the Olympic Games.
Yeah.
Right.
So what's the other side say?
Like,
well,
what's their story like if you talked to Sam Aaa,
what would he say that Pam would say he's Armenian and quit downplaying his
struggle for the struggle of the Palestinians.
He goes,
no one ever fucking respects those Armenians.
The Turks wipe them out.
Genocide.
I didn't even hear about it until Manny GAM Berean I was doing,
he kind of bursary of the Armenian genocide.
I,
I'm honest,
I just didn't know about it.
Um,
I'm ignorant to it.
It was because the only 1 million people died.
Got another word.
Fucking incredible that there's been so many horrible things like that that have
happened in the history of the world.
Rather,
you know that this Armenian genocide could be something that I wasn't aware of.
I mean it's hate [inaudible] hate them.
Well when I was kid I,
there was a kid that I used to train with who was a,
he was Turkish and they hated the Greeks.
Like Greeks and Turkish hated each other.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
No,
Pakistan,
India hates each other.
Cut boots.
I always thought it was so ridiculous.
It was like a kibbutz.
Turks and Greeks really in there in his eyes,
man.
It was like,
it was like a serious conversation.
It was just,
it was smart.
Yeah.
People get nationalistic.
I saw that bloody diva,
a documentary about him wherever he was from going to war,
you know,
internal strife,
maybe Czechoslovakia or Hungary and a,
and his teammates were like all abandoned him cause he wanted to like unity and
they wanted to break off.
And there's all these like people there that were like 25,
26,
like waving like the break off flags are getting really passionate.
I'm like,
well,
I've never been into shit like that.
Like I'm just,
we were all just like video games and whatever else.
There was like,
I can't imagine caring.
Well,
you had this enough,
but you would if you were there.
Yeah,
you will.
What are the east coast was trying to break off and there was this nationalistic
feel for the east coast and we're different than them.
Would you get caught up in it when you were little?
If you lived in that environment,
it's unlikely you would,
I guess be a Yankee Fan.
It's so easy to imitate your ass over.
It's so easy to get sucked up in the wave of your atmosphere.
It's just so weird when you think about how much human behavior can vary from
spot to spot.
We have no strife and soquel yeah,
that wasn't,
no,
no.
Uh,
dealing with the weather that are only problems are so many of us and we need a
lot of food.
Yeah.
No War overseas us,
we'd,
yeah,
your perspective here,
that's why someone like Paris Hilton can be so offensive to people in other
parts of the world.
Someone was just shallowly trying to attract attention to herself for no for no
reason at all.
And when,
when it's successful angers you.
It's like why is this even projected in front of me in a time where people are
just dying?
Paris Hilton.
Sure.
That's one of the reasons because there's so vapid cause behind wanting to be
famous only for being famous.
It's so vapid.
There's enough other people who are into it.
Well this is why they keep it on like that and the Kardashians.
The issue is it opened up a whole new category of human being and that category
of human being is the same as professional celebrity for no reasons.
Celebrity,
the the,
the,
the person who sneaks through the net and creates a whole new genre and it's
essentially Kim Kardashian is a reality celebrity,
but she's a hugely successful media personality and she did it from being just a
person who fucked a guy in a video.
I mean,
the whole thing is really like I'd heard dad was a lawyer.
Yeah.
And not only that,
a famous and a lawyer,
a famous lawyer who got Oj Simpson off,
but the whole thing behind it is that it's this,
this weird desire to get attention for no reason.
Other than that,
you want attention not offering anything.
You just want people to look at you.
You're not trying to sing,
he just want people to follow you around.
It's like a lot of people want that,
but only something that is so specific.
It must be so hard to arrange.
You know?
I mean,
you,
you're not trying to do anything.
Like,
I want to be famous.
What do you do?
I don't do anything.
But then people keep walking.
So then you feel entirely like,
well,
lots of great stuff.
Like what?
What are these great things you do?
Well,
she fucked on video.
I mean,
really that was the catalyst.
That's what started it all off.
So they both did the same thing.
They both fucked on video and that got him into the spotlight and now you're
getting the white spots now.
That's amazing,
man.
It is really an amazing trick.
It's fascinating.
It launched Paris,
hold them from it.
Just a model to of those reality shows.
Yeah.
And,
and,
but Kim Kardashians far eclipse Paris Hilton,
which is even more fantastic because Paris Hilton now does interviews and they
ask her,
are you worried that your population,
your popularity might be waning?
And she got up and left.
He got pissed and totally,
yeah.
Told her publicist deserve it.
Why would it go away?
That's still done.
Nothing.
So how could it go?
He's not thinking.
He's nearly as clearly as yo,
she's,
she's thinking,
why would a,
I'm still awesome,
Ashley.
For me,
she's probably a fine person.
Look,
I probably know she was probably not a five.
Why not?
She's self a titled,
no way.
She's probably a fine person.
I bet if she was sucking your cock,
I think you'd have to be great at sucking Dick [inaudible] with her.
You were hanging out with her and maybe she's a little crazy and she grew up
weird,
but hey,
she's a kind.
I would give her a chance because I want the blow job.
Yeah,
I think that'd be a real possibility.
I wouldn't be mean right away,
but there's no way she wouldn't be helping you right away,
but be batching your life in any way that's maybe not like a 5% chance.
Maybe get her high on mushrooms and straighten her out.
And Dude,
maybe it's you.
Maybe it's Ari who can straighten the whole thing out.
Who better than the founder mushroom fest.
That's right.
Liquid.
The aren't talking to swim fast.
Sure.
We're going to date now July,
2020 second and 23rd.
Yeah.
And by the way,
Ladies and gentlemen,
you don't have to go anywhere for shrimp fest.
Press comes to you.
Beautiful thing is trim fest is a trip and go,
oh,
don't do it.
If it's illegal way,
you are talking Shataki guy.
Yeah,
whatever.
don't do it.
If it's illegal,
you live.
We don't want you to do anything silly and going,
you know what I heard they made in Amsterdam,
they made them illegal because some kids,
uh,
jumped out of a building or something like that.
Bill Hicks joke,
young man on acid thought he could fly,
jumped off the roof.
What a tragedy goes.
What a tragedy when a deck,
if you thought he could fly,
why don't you start off on the ground first?
That's fine.
A lot of,
they all get a top speakers.
He goes,
oh,
lost two more on the world.
Got a little lighter.
That's funny.
Are you like a Hicks Joe?
See it's one of his best.
Yeah,
no,
I would ask to hear him say it taught me also had this,
you never hear a positive drug store in the news.
And I don't want to butcher this because I don't want to paraphrase it,
but as young man on acid,
you know,
and it was a beautiful positive message that he learned from acid.
Yeah,
I've got to go a bunch of great,
great drug jokes.
It's just weird that he quit drugs so young and then died so young.
The human body is so fucking for some folks so fragile.
You know,
I've been reading about these people that get these weird,
um,
like fibers growing out of their skin.
Have you heard of this?
What does that shit call again?
It's disgusting.
I was introduced to it on,
um,
there was like one of those,
a conspiracy theory shows like there's Jesse Ventura conspiracy theory shows and
they were talking about chem trails.
It was Kevin.
Sheryl,
yeah.
Something to do with chem shells.
More Jealous.
Hold on a second.
Let me,
let me pull this one.
Certain town in California and like a lot of them and then what people start
growing fibers out of.
This
totally sounds like complete horse shit.
But um,
the pictures are really bizarre man.
It's a,
it's,
there's like actual fiber that's coming out of their skin.
Like look,
all right,
can I check this out
for the ILS just says this is a,
this is something,
a fiber that they pulled out of someone's skin that had this more jealous.
I mean,
yeah,
it looks like a sweaters growing inside of you.
It looks like a mosquito down of that.
Yeah.
Well that picture is like pretty extreme,
but it goes around what a,
I mean,
what a fucking weird disease man.
And no one knows what the hell that is.
I mean,
these people,
some of them have gloves on and they have these fucking hairs that are growing
out of all over their body.
It's a relatively new problems,
seems to be growing in leaps and bounds throughout the u s even in other
countries.
Although condition where Jones possibly dates back to the 16 hundreds it's only
been since 2002 that it's become a modern,
dank concern.
It's probably has something to do it.
The Internet.
Wow.
Like wifi where we're growing wires and you imagine if that was really what it
is growing in tennis.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
crazy would be,
that's the next stage of development and autism and I'm tell us different
things.
We can't keep thinking that we're going to stay the way we are.
I know,
but it's,
is this supposed to happen so slowly that you would never in one lifetime notice
any change?
How do we know that?
You know,
there's been a lot of discrepancies about like how long it takes.
There's a,
there's a lot of arguments and disagreements about how long it takes for an
entity to evolve,
but one of the things that they know is the Congo.
The Congo is a kind of a crazy place where it used to be grasslands and then a
rain forests essentially grew there really rapidly and over a period of 2000
years became a dent,
massive rain forest where it used to be grasslands,
so all these grasslands animals got trapped in the jungle and had to evolve.
They had to change and one of them,
there's a,
an antelope thing called a Diker and how much time whims,
how much time is this?
Less than 2000 years.
Swims underwater and eat fish.
Really?
Yeah.
It's in the answer when family,
it's called,
I think it's called a Diker.
Wow.
Yeah.
It actually swims underwater and fucking eats fish.
It can swim under water for a hundred yards.
Whoa.
How is it?
What is,
where'd that come from?
I'll tell you why.
They had to figure out how to survive.
Somebody has the part like let's say grow a third eye.
Let's just say somebody had the first pure person as it slowly developed to see
through that somebody is going to be the first guy to have that.
If something like that would mutate and happen and become a successful
transition.
Yeah,
someone would have to be the first,
or at least have the first,
you know,
like stubs of it.
Like you know,
like some people are born with like a little stub of a tail,
you know?
Yeah.
What is that?
The Pink Tab,
but what,
how come chimps don't have tails and we're supposed to be related to chimps,
to chimps ever get they ever born with a little tail.
Most of us don't have it though.
No.
Very few of us have it.
I wonder if it's just a normal deformity.
Just a normal slip of it's your brother's.
Can anybody move it and then tail that would be fucked.
Imagine if you are a person you can wag your tail to as a cat tail that would
you even want to take it off?
It's a cat tail.
Yeah.
You'd probably find some weird pride out of it,
but it's like it's not
because of it.
Ah.
You know what?
If you could do that flying,
we'll end this shit like no problem.
Cause you gotta kiss because of that.
You know,
cats have the most ridiculous balance,
man.
I've tried to push cats off of like banisters.
I'm lucky enough that pastor batch and the cats like,
oh not all the way off like a weeble wobble then right back slide sideways on a
banister.
She see that video that chimp versus the cat UFC match.
No,
it's bad ass.
Google it sometime.
It's great.
It's a,
it's a little monkey and a cat fighting or they're really fighting or they
playing.
They're playing.
But the cat has,
some cats have really good Jujitsu.
Oh they grew up around chit chats or you know,
we're,
we're just comfortable with them cause they're really tiny.
They're all fearful in Israel.
All cats.
Yeah.
They brought him in and nobody has them as pets because they're so fucking
disgusting.
They brought them into to hunt rats and they just switched yet then they right.
No natural enemies.
You guys should kill him off because I bet you got toxo plasma like a
motherfucker all out there just out there dead when that side of the road or
does everywhere.
They're like a problem.
Yeah.
I don't like fake tough to,
they're tough mean man.
Feral cats or little moms.
Oh Way.
Yeah.
They'll fuck you up dude.
They'll,
and they'll jump at you too if you,
if you corner a feral cat man,
be fucking can I can say or maybe I just thought was just a normal cat and it
was just crazy.
Well feral cats or just wildcats.
The,
it's an amazing difference.
the way they behave.
Barn cats or you're talking about,
I mean I'm sure farm cats can be feral to cancer.
Just retarded big.
The guy straight up on walls so high.
Like how are you going to get up there?
Feral cats or feral kitten and I uh,
they only will connect themselves to one or two people.
They were like,
yeah,
they really hate people.
I was the only person that this cat could like trust enough to pick up horses.
And I could never,
if he was something was wrong with him,
I can never bring him to the vet.
You couldn't,
no one can take care of him but me,
no one can even hold them at me.
And I got him because a friend of mine,
uh,
she,
was living in this apartment building and her and her boyfriend found them
underneath the house.
They found like a whole litter of kittens and apparently the mother had died or
something like that though it was a wild cat and she gave birth.
So they captured all the kittens.
And uh,
then they started trying to find homes for them.
And I said,
ah,
I can't,
it's such a crazy story I got to take.
So I took it and I,
uh,
I had to stay in a room with it for two days because it was so crazy and so
nuts,
like to get a comfortable with me,
I had to be like next to it for two days.
So I just put a room in my house.
Uh,
I see my guest room,
I put a litter box in there,
put his cat food in there and put a couple of notebooks and a,
some books.
Nope.
I said,
yeah,
sorry,
write shit down and uh,
and then I'll,
I'll do some reading and just hang out with his fucking cat for a couple of days
to get comfortable with you.
Yeah.
So that's what I did for two days.
Every time I'd go near him he would fucking climb up like there's curtains,
climb up the curtains go fucking crazy and I go,
come download it buddy.
Calm down,
calm down.
And then I touch him and then he would start powering and par like really loud.
He went from intuit check,
fear and terror to like purring so loudly are so happy that I'm actually taking
care of him.
He didn't know what's going on.
He doesn't know why this big giant pink thing turn it down toward much.
Well I had to turn them into my buddy,
but I was the only one that can touch him.
Like even anywhere else was supposed to get us wrong.
And even me,
I would like if I'd come up to him,
like I had to take him to the vet once and this is what a really bad time,
man.
It was fucking bad.
This cat jacked my arm.
I had to throw a towel over them and tackle them.
Really?
Yeah.
And was fierce fighting man.
He was fighting and then I brought him to the vet and I told them that like,
I go,
listen man,
this cat is feral.
Like don't worry,
we've had 25 years here.
And we gave them that cat.
And they said,
well you weren't kidding when you said he was fair.
I go,
yeah,
it's a feral cat man.
Yeah.
It was
a cat.
That cat is the craziest cat we've ever had any of that go.
Yeah.
That's a wildcat.
Big black crazy cat.
Hmm
me.
I didn't in the army with the kittens.
What they had to make them raise.
Oh yeah.
I wonder if will Ferrell,
if every on you've got to listen to the story that made him raised.
My Dad was a special,
a special,
what was it called?
The army special forces.
Yeah.
And up back then.
And um,
and what they do is they make you learn how to take care of things you don't
just so you can know how to like care for your,
your other gis or whatever.
But uh,
so they give you a kitten just like the,
they gave you that egg to care for her and like a middle school,
they'll give you a kid,
you've got to raise it for,
uh,
for like two weeks or a month,
I forgot.
And you've got to make sure nothing goes wrong with it.
If something goes wrong with it,
if it gets sick,
you're in trouble.
You got to take care of it.
In addition to running all your laps and doing everything and doing all your
regular chores and a at the end of the two weeks or to present this healthy
kitten.
And then once you present a healthy kid and they go,
okay,
now snap his neck and they may get snapped his neck right there so they can shut
you off and turned it into a machine.
Wow.
After you've cared for it for two weeks.
[inaudible]
bare hands,
not even like give it up for adoption.
Fuck.
What was,
what was the story in the Bible where God was telling someone to kill his son?
Abraham?
Why?
What was the story behind those test
to kill Isaac is a kill eyes.
And uh,
it was,
uh,
was it not as firstborn what size he was first born.
Um,
and then this is when those split off happened between the Arabs and the Jews.
It was right then.
Really?
Yeah.
Why?
Because Isaac's brother was technically the first born,
so he should have gotten the birthright and the Jews say that he,
he didn't,
he went to Isaac and then Jacob.
Okay.
So God comes to Abraham,
I want you to kill us.
So he takes me to his mountain.
Yeah.
Take your son.
It takes them to this mountain,
puts them up on an altar.
Um,
yeah.
And um,
and then he goes to raise a knife over his head and
God sent a sign.
He sent the ram,
which is a normal thing.
You sacrificed.
He sent a ram right then.
And that was a sign even though rams were indigenous to that area at the time.
It was definitely a sign from God,
some retard God who couldn't fucking get his full words out.
So we just have to ramp and that obviously means don't kill your son killed this
ram instead of them blow the horn once or twice a year cause that's so obvious.
That's what it means.
Cause he couldn't have just said,
hey,
don't kill your son and that's a good enough sign.
He had to send a ram to walk by
such stupid idiots.
Shit.
Once you realize what you're getting older,
you were a little kid and you got sent to Israel to study this 10 12 hours a day
like already did.
I mean you'd probably be pretty passionate about how are we supposed to take
that for granted?
He sent a sign,
it was a ram walk by.
Oh yeah,
that's a sign.
Obviously crazy was easy.
He was about to kill us,
kill his son because God wanted him to.
And then the issue became like,
while we were still religious with issue became like,
well why would God command that?
Why would that be a test for him?
Why would you do it?
And I just wanted to see,
you knew if he was able to,
but there was a test,
you're God,
you knew it was going to be able to,
so like why wouldn't you just say,
okay,
go ahead.
You're up for it.
You know you would know more than anybody about how much of what you read when
you were reading the Talmud,
how much of what you've read had been translated several times.
How many times had it been translated before it got to,
when you read it in Modern Day Hebrew,
how many times has it had been transferred to get to that?
No.
Well it was,
it's,
it's the Torah is written exactly the same as it always was.
Oh wait.
Yeah.
So you read it in ancient Hebrew,
even with the same shapes of the letters,
he said the old testament that's different.
Yeah.
Then this whole mode is that was handed down orally for awhile and they were
afraid it was gonna get lost because of some dispersion.
So they wrote it down.
But the oldest versions of the Bible,
of the ancient Hebrew versions,
right,
except for the Dead Sea Scrolls,
which not technically considered the Bible,
even though some of the stories are not 100% on those,
right?
So they said that the oldest versions were in ancient Hebrew,
that they,
the real problem was that they,
when they translated it to Greek and Latin,
they said that they only knew like three quarters of the words in ancient Hebrew
this specific meetings to words,
but they don't know all those because some of those words didn't make it to
modern Hebrew.
And they don't really have a good lineage to say like,
where,
where was this exact words?
Like if I said,
um,
let's just say gently or lovingly,
they could mean the same thing.
It's certain times a gently said,
whatever I lovingly said,
it's simply similar,
but there's differences.
And that's what we have two different words.
When was this transition between ancient,
he ruined modern hero.
Probably during the dispersion we got cast out to all different,
that's when we got white juries and black jurors.
After that one's went to the,
what year was that?
I don't know.
And so so Israel or the Jews?
The the modern Jews.
They kept the certain modern version of Hebrew.
It was like 4,000 years ago.
Probably something like that.
But you guys also have numbers,
which now they brought it back.
They brought it back when they,
when they went with them.
Sort of a modern Hebrew I guess,
but they just sort of made it when they decided like what should our language
back?
And they're like,
let's bring the Hebrew was a dead language.
Oh,
it was a dead language Korean and all those people said,
um,
when was this?
1948 47 holy shit.
Hebrew was a dead language notice.
Wow.
That's crazy number to speaking.
And there's some people that won't,
that they're treated is like holy,
that's a little much.
But the truth is holding,
they won't speak at the only speak good.
It's during the week.
And then Shabbat,
that's when he hit him with the Hebrew.
What is she had it?
What's a different or weird bastardized mixture.
It's like southern talk creole.
It's like not quite English cause the mixture of Hebrew and like dramatic mixed
with whatever country you're from.
When you talk to get you hard,
there's no such things to get us to know because I mean when it talks about its
old.
Oh really?
The Jewish?
Yeah,
like nobody talks
like that anymore.
How much is different in that and and modern Hebrew.
Yiddish.
It's mostly dramatic.
German.
So you most most kids understand it like Israeli kids with the German kids,
you better get it better.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
God that's so incredible.
When you stop and think about how many different languages there are.
Oh yeah.
They all developed somewhat similarly in how long was it before they actually
started writing shit down?
How long did they have language before they are actually wrote things down?
Because I've waited a while before they put signs to it.
Probably tens of thousands.
It didn't happen the other way.
Yeah.
I don't know how long the first written language was,
but I don't,
I don't believe it was more than 10,000 years ago.
Yeah.
Which is really like nothing.
Here's kind of cranes.
It's Kinda hurts your head when he stopped.
As long as we've been able to communicate without being there.
Stop and trying to put your head around that.
And the way,
this is what I would always use as an example,
if I was in a crowd safe,
I was doing a comedy show and there was 100 people in the audience.
I would say what you guys represent,
if you lived your lives,
birth to death,
it's just a little room,
a little tiny group of people,
100 people.
But,
but what you represent in terms of potential life,
his whole life,
the next person was born.
Exactly.
If they lived there alone,
their lives,
birth to death,
to the Max,
which is like a hundred years,
which is the most anybody ever lives.
They represent 10,000 years.
That's as long as that's incredible.
That's as long as we know about human beings.
Wow.
But like 4,000 years ago when we got the Bible around.
That's right.
Right.
100 people.
That's when not everyone was like better.
One lived a hundred years.
It's not 10,000 a hundred people living a hundred years.
100 people living tennis is a thousand yeah.
Yeah.
That's incredible man.
Stop and think about that 10,000 years ago and it's just a little tiny room full
of people living there.
Last birth to death represents the big fat long.
The distance between us of 10 day and nothing written.
I have three math jokes.
Yours is way better than all three of those three.
What jokes?
Math jokes.
I Call Matt jokes where there's numbers involved so they actually have to think
before they laugh.
That's not really a math joke,
but it's a what the fuck thinking thing.
It's like you want to check as math.
It takes her a second.
I've been really getting into game or game of Thrones first.
Oh,
it's amazing.
It's the best show I've ever watched.
I watched the whole for cause,
but it's like I'd love that kind of Shit.
I love that.
Conan the barbarian type swords and sorcery shit.
I love that stuff.
I love it.
So I'm,
I'm enjoying the fuck out of it.
But it's making me think,
I mean,
although obviously this is a work of,
you know,
fantasy fiction,
it makes me think of what it must've been like,
you know,
if you had to live like these people lived,
with swords on horses.
I mean there was a time where people actually lived like that.
That is how they hunted.
They used bows and arrows.
They did live in these houses.
They did have castles and they did have armies and they did have moats.
I mean,
these are all realistic,
realistic depictions of a certain time,
you know,
take away the sorcery and all the other crazy stuff.
There was people that in just a few thousand years ago live like that.
It's hard to wrap your head around how short of a distance it is between that
time when people lived like in the Robin Hood days and today it's like nothing.
You,
it'd be cool though.
It would still be cool having like,
Hey,
I got these new silver horse shoes.
Have you seen these things torsional or you know,
even though you live back in those days,
people were still making new things up and like,
but the things where like differently they make up a new thing.
Every like red errors thing would come.
I'm sure there was little things here and there though.
Just like everything.
Yeah,
I'm sure there was a few intervention.
It was so lame.
Like well then they got Chinese finger traps.
They were blown away by that.
That does a party favor.
But the Black Smith back then was like the apple,
like you would come in to come look at this thing.
I mean,
you know,
this is a new layer of artisans.
That's something that's really getting lost.
You know we talked about that won't Aubrey was on here last,
we talked about that Musashi documentary.
No,
it was a,
they showed how they used to make Samurai swords and there's a few people alive
but still make them that way today.
It's crazy.
Some,
I mean you have to be the ultimate craftsmen.
I mean,
if you and I were left alone to figure it out on our own for a million years,
we'd never figured out how to make a fucking Samurai sword.
The way they do it is so incredible.
They,
they hammer it down,
then they fold it over and then they hammer it down.
Like they keep flattening it and hammering it and flattening it and hammering
until it becomes this intense steel that you could just fucking slice through
bamboo.
It mean it's really amazing watching the,
the,
the artisan work,
the craftsmanship and the,
the knowledge passed down through generations and generations of how to make a
sword.
You know,
when you stop and think about it,
it's like how many people are out there in the world today that know how to make
anything even remotely like that.
Everything we're buying that's manufactured is manufactured in some sort of a
factor.
And if you're going to buy a sword,
this is a big machine's going to cut it and make it with a computer on a laser
and shit.
There's not going to be some Japanese dude and flip flops with wooden bottom
shoes.
Fucking wrong.
It's wild to watch,
man.
It's wild.
It's wild to watch what people used to have to do to make something,
you know,
it's,
it really,
really makes you appreciate like how ridiculously easy,
easy limiting us.
Now people are like,
I liked it better the other way.
I'm like,
why?
She's like,
you just melt rocks,
right?
Or something like that.
Yeah.
You have to have a minor have to in the rocks to make steel.
You have to add things to it too.
It's not just iron now to make steel,
I think you have to,
we should actually look that up and like back in the back in the back in the
day,
say,
what did they do?
Just took some rocks and while they have to heat things,
eat them up.
And they had a,
they had a mind the metal.
Yup.
Okay.
They have pockets of metal in the ground.
They have to add stuff to,
uh,
to the steel.
They have to add stuff.
Tired.
It's combined.
It's an alloy.
Technically it says according to Wikipedia made by combining iron and another
element,
usually carbon.
And when carbon is used it's content and the steels between oh 0.2% and 2.1% by
weight dependent upon the grade.
Who figured that out?
That was given to us.
So I guess they had an ad shit.
So it's like harder to someone else was like,
why don't you add a carbon?
And the first guy was like,
what are you talking about?
I mean that's been around for a long ass time to,
so who was the first person that somebody told somebody that's,
that doesn't seem like that makes salience or no,
you know what the crazy shit in the world is steel cable.
Who would have ever found some metal in the ground and thought for a second that
someone is going to take this shit and have so much of it did.
They're going to have a fucking 5,000 foot long cable made us steel and they're
going to use that to suspend giant beams that weighed several hundred tons over
an ocean.
Did you leave like steel cable,
steel cable is crazy.
Someone figured out how to take metal it out of the ground and stretch that
shit.
It's hard.
How the fuck are you?
How is it moving around?
How are you making cables out of this?
What did you do?
They figured out how to not just make it but make it so it's big enough to pull
boats.
You can have giant,
huge ones that are there.
They're wider around in your body is,
and that's a cable and we just said take it for granted.
Oh well I'm gonna just get a cable and put a winch on the front of my jeep in
case I get stuck out there.
All four Waylon.
You know people that have winches and shit so they can pull cars out,
would be like to be the cool guy who can pull you in an area that's still
capable of driving in the mud.
Yeah,
that's fucking steel cable.
That winches steel cable.
Man,
I get caught up and now she's going to snap your arm off.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It'll rip your body apart.
Steel cable.
They can pick up trees with that shit.
You gotta put a winch on.
It depends on the pounds,
the power of the winch.
But if it's good winch can pull hundreds of pounds.
That's my black guys like it so much.
I always hear him.
What?
Like taking it from buildings,
stealing cables.
Oh yeah.
That's a little cable stealing you.
Silly bitch though.
Steel cable.
Like you don't pay for it,
Brian.
Oh,
not like steel cables.
Thinking about the first guy to invent wires who figured out how to stretch out
some metals.
So real heroes,
like the first guy who actually steel cable that somebody fucking figure that
out and then share that information with people.
I remember I used to have everybody did who figured that out though?
There was a guy that lives in the neighborhood that would leave up a thing when
satellite dishes first came out,
he would leave up like on telephone poles.
This is how the dumpster,
it was in 1993 he leave up a phone number and it would say,
you know,
fix your satellite box to catch any,
any channel.
And so you would give this guy your card and then they would,
uh,
they would,
he would,
uh,
he would come back and bring the card back to you and it was doctored and the
card could get everything.
I've got every paper view movie,
every porn,
every,
you know,
everything that happened it would get,
but it would never work.
It would really,
it would work for like a day is working with us.
They would send a signal to fuck it up.
Yeah,
they crush it and that,
and then it just got to a silly point where I think me and my roommate were
like,
why are we doing this?
Pay For this?
We want this stuff so we can actually have a TV on.
So stupid.
You know,
I saw at the bar,
did I say how I saw at the barber shop in Atlanta that the guys had hacked their
Mac apple TV and it had like every single channel,
Hbo,
every movie that was in theaters.
It was just like,
just like watch now,
watch now.
And it was set up so cool.
Like,
I forgot all about it,
but whatever it is,
you can live off of the just that like it had streaming channels had used during
channel.
It had,
it had everything you could possibly want.
New Movies in theaters.
Oh,
I got a disturbing story for you.
I remember wanting to Vancouver.
Yes.
And uh,
we went to visit that pot shop
but they couldn't sell to us cause we're right out of state.
But somebody hooked us up anyway.
He got fired for that,
for hooking us up.
Oh Man.
I got fired for it cause he shouldn't have looked this up.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's so bad.
Right.
It was like,
he was like,
no,
I can't help.
But then he went outside and just gave us some,
yeah,
he couldn't sell us any.
So he gave us some and you gave them tickets to the UFC after that?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
That guy got fired.
Fired.
I was like,
oh,
this is the right way to handle it.
Probably Brag too much about the tickets for the EOC.
They're reliable.
I don't know.
I dead sucks though.
Sorry to hear about that buddy.
I was like,
aw man.
that's a real really bad for you.
Some day it's going to be easy to go anywhere and be able to buy.
We just so I can go anywhere and buy a beer how it should be.
You should be a fucking tax paying grown adult who walks in there and act like a
gentleman and picks up whatever the fuck you need.
Whether you would like to buy a bottle of wine to go with dinner or that you'd
like to get an eighth of weed cause you and you check.
You're going to watch movies and fuck.
How about that?
Is that okay?
Am I allowed to do that?
You fucking controlling duty by the counter purchase to go there with the key.
Yeah.
She'd be super easy.
Here's your Id.
Can I see your id?
Okay.
You're 21 here's your weed.
Mr. Should fear take it easy.
21 snots sense bitch.
No,
no,
not for weed has been 21 I don't think it should be for which bill to get them
high.
Really Young.
I took half an Adderall today.
This is like the second time I've ever done Adderall before.
This is the first time that I feel like it.
It's like a sativa.
I think if you are a fan of Adderall,
if you've got a really good sativa,
it'd be pretty similar.
So I think so.
What's your
body all jacked up and moving?
It's similar in some way,
but here's the deal Brian.
When you say half an
Adderall,
you have to understand there are different values for different pills.
Yeah,
I slept five milligram Adderall is far different than the 40 that you might've
had split in half,
by the way.
Powerful Ari Shaffir tee shirts.
These are awesome watching on each gene.
You guys didn't have to wear them while I was here to look at his tongue.
It's got some stuff.
Where can anybody by these dudes,
these are actually really cool to have them online and like a week or two,
but right now my live dates nice.
Well we pester Ari on on Twitter,
a,
r I.
to make sure that he comes on strong and LSD and ecstasy on his tongue.
And there's the pink elephants on parade.
There's a hard bitch on your head.
Login like a black shirt with a mushroom leaf right next to it.
There's only one place.
I can't wear this shirt though,
like comedy club to be kind of weird.
Where it bitch,
somebody scared I wear,
and I'll wear this on stage.
If I'd know.
If I knew that you had this,
I would've wore this for my special.
Yeah.
Really?
That'd be a cool shirt.
I want to totally wore this for my special.
How about this?
I'll wear this for my next special committing to it and I was writing it out.
There'll be gone.
Does this,
it's 2012 shirt.
I want to have a different story where this next year.
Oh yeah.
My goal now we're going to do it.
You're gonna try to do I have to do in Atlanta is to try to do another one in a
year.
Yeah,
let's talk about that.
Do.
Let's hear some new jokes every year.
It's like some notes of yours right now.
Oh,
I can't tell you
like here's the program really helped me when,
when you're thinking in terms of this with Thompson grower as bill bitter about
it and he broke it down to what an hours and he goes,
that's five minutes a month.
So if you get pretty much any new month that you're like,
am I in five minutes ahead of where I was?
And just time it that way and just keep a pace for yourself where you're at the
head of pace or behind pace.
I had five new minutes the first time on stage because I,
there was a bunch of shit that I had written that I,
the last couple of months I hadn't committed to any new stuff.
I was just trying to just completely tighten the old stuff except this
circumcision beard that just came out of nowhere.
I couldn't stop it.
I had to put it on and it will,
it just fit in with all this other shit I had to.
But other than that,
oh my writing that I had from all that time is all bank rolled.
So I just have to go over the writing.
You know the fucking just nuttiness I just have to go over there cause you're
like,
I've got stuff right now.
So since I did still keep writing I,
there's a lot of ideas.
I just have to sort of set them out.
But this will make yourself go through him.
Did you end up doing the baby?
No.
No,
I didn't do that one.
that's two specials.
A dumb joke.
It's going to be like,
no,
no.
I had a thought I hadn't thought.
Here's what you do.
What you do.
A video just really excites me to video.
I should get it out there on your own youtube account.
Yeah.
Hire some actors.
I mean that bit tray.
That bit is three or four years old and so ready to go and be done.
Have done Barris be the baby.
Yeah,
it's,
I have,
I'm so immature with my sense of humor that has so many jokes about someone
getting blown.
Just actually use that to promote the special when you have it.
Here's one for the next time you go to a big club,
just tape it Brian fucking tape from the back.
Maybe behind and you get a close up
of him and get a far away shot of him and cut those together.
I'll go behind you.
Well,
no,
not behind
caustically Adderall.
Um,
but it was,
uh,
it was the Atlanta thing.
Couldn't it went great.
Couldn't have gone any better.
Man.
These crowds are completely different crowds.
The crowds that we're getting now are 100% podcast fans and it's like,
it's like hanging out and doing a show in front of our friends.
It's like a bunch of friends that we don't know that one.
The other people who come just to come for shows,
they're like,
oh,
this is a really fun thing.
Do are so overwhelmingly nice.
It's,
it's crazy.
I don't know how we did it.
I don't know what,
what exact the cottle exactly.
The combination was to create that,
but that's very unusual.
It's very unusual when you talk to people that work at clubs and people that
work at theaters,
they go your crowds and nicest crowd we've ever seen ever.
Pretty cool.
It's even close.
The good tippers.
They're good.
They're generous and they were fucking so pumped for the show.
Dude.
It was nuts.
I was so comfortable.
It's the only time I've ever done a special where I didn't feel at all like,
Oh shit,
I'm filming right now.
Or it was completely in the groove.
I had done so much standup leading up to that too.
So yeah,
I did all my work and then on top of that,
the crowd was amazing,
but now it's that.
The big challenge is to now to create a whole new hour,
so I have to really sit down and I have all these scattered notes.
I'm going to have to do some organizing isis,
isis,
we're going to do some ice house shows.
Can we do Wednesday?
See if we could do Wednesday?
Probably not.
If we can,
let's do it.
This is what Louis said to after you do the first year,
when you start the same process again the next year,
and it seems as daunting as it does right now,
you'd be like,
oh no,
I know this leads to a new hour of material.
Yeah,
so it's okay,
I can do this.
It's a bench pressing to get bigger.
Well,
I know that writing to me is just like,
it's like doing rounds on the bag or doing minutes on an elliptical machine.
You build endurance,
you build like a groove and right now you know I'm in good writing shape.
You know?
I felt like when I,
when I write a lot I get in a good way it's a muscle and now I can,
I think it comes,
it comes out better the more you use it and it comes out your,
your editing skills on the fly get better.
Better right now than you were five years ago.
20 years ago.
No.
Yeah.
I'm so happy that I,
you know,
I always wondered what would happen as I got older.
Like if my standup,
it starts to suck one day.
You know,
I always worried about that.
I always worried about like hitting a peak and then not being good anymore.
It seems like there's a plateau you can get.
It's like Kinda like pool where you can play later through stand up later
interiors.
It's not like a 40 year old retirement moment.
Yeah.
Well,
I think it has to do with your physical health too.
You know,
if you get depressed and you feel like shit,
I bet your comedy is going to start to not be as fun and not be as good.
I think part of the commitments,
well,
he's different kinds of standup,
you know,
standups.
Comedy almost depends on him being miserable.
I think every,
like almost every comic I know.
It seems like they're depressed and miserable.
They don't have to be,
it's not necessarily,
but that can fuel you.
You know?
It can fuel you to go up there and get that charge.
Where I know in times of my life where I wasn't happy,
I would go on stage and kill it.
At least feel like I can do something.
Yeah.
It will at least feel like I'm capable of something.
Like if I could go on stage,
you know,
from feeling like a loser,
I'm feeling depressed.
I go on stage and get a bunch of people to laugh.
I'll decide,
okay,
I'm not,
I'm not bad at this.
I did a good job with this.
I go,
yeah,
I can feel a little better now.
A little pick me up short term.
So they all give you a standing ovation before you even went on stage.
I was nuts.
It was,
couldn't have been better,
couldn't not have been better.
And there was a lot of traffic because there were some crazy basketball games
going on at the same time.
And yeah,
we,
um,
we've got stuck.
Like there was,
it was really hard for everybody to get there.
So the show didn't even start for like a half an hour late.
So like everybody was building up.
So when the lights went off and when,
you know,
I came on the microphone to introduce Joey,
they went fucking crazy.
It was so funny because,
um,
my manager and uh,
you know,
Shandra and Jeff there,
they're the best.
I've been with Jeff since I was an open miker essentially.
Like he came and found me in Boston when I was a scrub.
And I think that one of the main reasons why I've been successful is that I
don't have to think about the business stuff.
I just let him think about it.
And I just to do my comedy.
I don't have to worry about it cause cause he's the best.
But they were like,
let's Ah,
have you introduced offstage?
Like just say your name clean and you come out alone.
I'm like,
no,
she always got to bring me up.
What's your fans will want to see that too.
Five seconds.
Joey has to bring me up this.
That's,
that's the Voodoo.
Thank you for the suggestion.
We're not going to do that.
I appreciate your input,
but we're not.
But they were like,
well let's just try it once.
I'm like,
nope,
Joey's going to bring me up.
This is just,
it doesn't have to make sense.
It's just Joe is a product to talk about it.
It's brought me up and every special for the past eight,
nine years,
whatever it's been.
So they couldn't do it in Canada,
right?
Yeah.
Dunkin and I tried to do a chant at the beginning of one of the specialist,
but it didn't work at all.
So
yeah,
we were way too begged for,
we came up with that idea.
We talked,
we'd get the whole crowd,
the to Oma long and we got like maybe 30 people and then everyone's like,
what's happening?
What are you doing?
They were waiting for the punchline.
That never was,
that shit is such a trip.
The second show Joe turned to me and goes,
do you want to go up and do five minutes?
And we just got done smoking a joint and I was stoned out of my mind.
I like that was I got to go up and it was pretty cool but it was still hard to
judge that many people like,
like,
like you said,
30 people was doing it and it seemed like,
you know,
it's 30 out of a million.
I don't want to say your material dude,
but the one joke you have is fucking funny.
He's got one joke.
I just,
I,
I can't say anything that'll give away.
It's one jug.
That's one of them where I go,
damn,
I wish I thought that one up.
You know when you hear somebody say something and just like fires off the door,
that's a fun one to play with.
So much to do.
And watch over a thousand people laugh at was really fun.
It's fun to watch someone go up that's never been in front of that,
that big of a crowd.
But they all were really friendly.
Like when you went on stage,
they give you a huge round of applause.
I know you're probably so then had a made you feel like,
you know,
they weren't,
they were,
they were happy to see it so much better.
Yeah.
Feeling so much better than the feeling you get when it's like,
oh cool,
you guys already know me.
Nobody takes more Internet shit than Brian.
Nobody takes more.
There's,
you have more haters and more irrational,
angry people who love it though.
Right?
A certain party.
No,
no,
no.
It's not comfortable.
And then there's always some weird sort of analysis of Brian and I's
relationship.
Look,
Brian and I are very different,
but obviously we like each other.
You know,
never had a job for more than 10 10 years
is a long time.
We were going to go along.
But we like each other.
I mean,
we liked each other a lot.
We're,
I mean,
I would say love,
but it sounds gay because he's right next to me.
But of course I love him.
We,
the reason why we've been,
we keep doing this is because it works well,
don't you say?
Yeah,
he says ridiculous shit.
he thinks it.
But you say also some things that I don't think of.
You know,
you're,
you come at things from a weird perspective sometimes,
you know,
but for whatever reason,
people,
people get angry at shit.
That man,
all you have to do is take one thing.
You'll interject one thing and it will derail a conversation and sometimes it
works and sometimes you derail something and it becomes really funny and
sometimes it doesn't.
I mean,
who knows?
You never know until you try.
That's what people don't understand that listening.
But they'll get so fucking angry at you and you're like,
dude,
get up and go out to,
there's a conversation going on somewhere and you're listening in.
That's it.
That's all that's happening here.
There's no reason to get fucking spastic angry,
fucking violent.
Mad,
like relaxed.
If you interrupt one more time,
I'm going to kick him in his guns.
That's the only way you've expressed like,
oh,
that's all they're trying to express.
That's the only way they can do that online.
That's all they feel is.
So I have to say that I'm going to kill you.
I appreciate criticism.
I really do.
And it sounds like I don't,
cause I just get mad and blocked people when they say coffee things on Twitter
or whatever.
But I'm not gonna argue with you,
man.
If you can't communicate with me like a normal human being,
if you can't communicate with me like you would if you just,
I don't care who I ever met.
If,
if I,
if I had to have a conversation with Adolf Hitler,
okay.
If I had to go back in time and have a conversation with Adolph Hitler,
I wouldn't start calling them a comment and say crazy stupid shit to him.
Even though I know he's a piece of shit,
I don't got anything.
So where's that going to help you?
It's not going to help me at all.
I already know what he has.
I want to base all of my interactions with someone and how they interact with
me,
not how I want to know about their past.
I want to,
you know,
I want to know you're dealing with a criminal or whatever the fuck you're
dealing with,
but you should be as as yeses as possible to someone I find always gets upset
when people like writing shitty things.
I'm like,
why do you care?
That's just some shitty person.
Who Cares?
That's just a screaming baby he gets,
he gets Cody worried about.
Yeah.
I see people go back and forth and fight with people on Twitter and like,
Whoa,
really?
Yes.
It was like,
fuck you.
You fucking cunt.
I call Dana White goes,
wow,
Dana white has like multiple day.
Really?
We can't do that.
There's no point.
What do you like?
What are you going to prove to them that they're wrong?
Has that ever happened to their history of Twitter data to prove to someone that
they're wrong?
Dana actually enjoys it though.
Really does a great boss Boston.
He still likes to fight.
He still needs it.
He enjoys it.
He's good at it.
He goes to their fucking pictures and makes a lot of all the pictures and yeah,
it's,
it's funny,
man.
It's funny he gets into it,
but he does it all with a big smile on his face.
I've watched them do it,
you know,
he's not like mean obviously Dana White and successful as fuck.
He's not really worried about what some twatty 15 year old kid from the middle
of nowhere on Twitter is saying about it.
He thinks it's fun.
20 as good words.
Flighty.
It's a sweet word.
And by the way though,
people that came to Joe Shaw,
I want you to come to my show May 12th where's your show?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Denver.
Yeah,
the comedy works.
We'll take a totally different place in the world.
Well,
the machine,
I mean your fans,
your fans,
people.
Okay.
That's a Shitty segue right there.
So we thought that,
I realize we just jumped off the subject and I was like,
oh,
as we're talking about the special,
do you think will pharaoh when he brings his cats too,
like a shelter that,
that they,
he has had many times like they had asked,
they accidentally killed a cat and what will Pharrel brings his cats to shelters
and they feed goes out of town and he takes a drink.
Just cat to a show.
I mean like if he did,
do you think he would constantly have dead cats?
Why?
Cause be like a pharaoh,
you know,
you know his last name would mix things up,
some paperwork or so he fucking,
I just kicked on defending you when you come with that.
I was just,
these are like,
no,
it's fine.
That's what it is that you should write down and revisit later and work on the
wording.
I was incredibly disappointed that in on purpose just because if Ari's Berlin,
I'm incredibly disappointed with you.
Brian shut you up.
Nice for the rest of the show.
You could have walked away hero,
but no,
no.
This guys right now.
This motherfucker,
I swear it's like find your red pick right in your fucking stupid tee shirt.
Fuck you marry room.
I fucking chow man.
I still off of your whipped to goal.
You got really high this time.
Yeah.
We got wait cavalry and his Adderall.
Totally different.
Yeah.
You're,
you're on a drink.
That iced coffee on top of that as a sign.
I don't think he was doing those things.
Adderall was like,
no,
that's a weight loss time.
Is that what you're doing it for now?
I'm just trying to be focused right here.
Oh yeah.
You're so good.
Being stickers right now is a third full.
Doesn't see that cell.
I want to say that's a 40 milligram or not.
That is the craziest,
you know,
by the way was going be passing this shit around in front of a camera.
Hey,
remember what our friend I use Ustream told us.
Well,
we'll show you after I got a prescription for it.
It's just a Baggie.
Alright dude.
It could,
it could be implied as some sort of,
well,
it's,
it's made by pharmaceutical companies and it makes people happy.
Yeah.
I know.
Who has a fulltime prescription.
He takes it every day.
People who have like severity,
do they take it to calm them down instead of hype them up?
I don't feel calm.
I feel like no,
you're getting a totally different reaction.
They are.
Do you feel,
um,
you feel its way to no.
Medical doctor would prescribe it to you?
I feel like I'm on a coming down from a cope.
When did you take it?
Uh,
four hours ago.
You got plenty of time.
How long is it going?
Coming down?
Size nine tangents.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ to more podcasts.
And I said,
perfect.
Wow Dude.
That's uh,
uh,
you sure that it's healthy,
that stuff.
It's not like salad or
is it drugs?
Is it dangerous?
No overdose on it.
Do you take,
I took half a pill though.
So would you quit saying half a pill just told you I'm such a huge difference.
You're just stop saying that.
You just find out how much you're taking one five milligram pill.
It was,
it's the same as Catholics Horse Brian.
There might be a horse dosage if
strong one's available.
And you took a half.
I've heard of a 10 and a 20 you get that cracked out right now,
son.
Just whoa.
Easy.
Just give me a taste.
Come down from Adderall.
Is there a way to get,
I think you crush.
You just cook.
Is there anything you can take to like two in order to come down like Adderall
lighter does it at the end of the day though,
my friend was on it all the time.
Said that sometimes if he has to do something late at night,
like a late night show,
it's badly timed and you know,
because he takes his stuff at a certain time every day.
Oh yeah.
There's a late night show.
It fucks him up.
Oh yeah.
I guess that's why,
but if I take one of those five hour energies,
no,
not,
doesn't get too hyper.
He's done.
By the time the late night show rolls around,
he's over.
He's,
he's tired.
He can't take it too late because they won't be able to sleep on that exact a
mundo.
Medicated Medicaid.
We live in a strange world.
New Drug.
What is it?
A Cop told me in Austin Krokodil oh,
that's a,
that's a drug from a,
um,
Russia.
Yeah.
A lot of guys that were hooked on heroin or taking it and it makes their skin
rot.
It makes your skin rocks.
We can see the bone through your skin.
Have you seen it?
They call it something else like meow meow or something like that.
Maybe.
I Dunno.
It's called Krokodil though.
It so is that what it is?
Horrifying.
Yeah.
They said it takes about two years to kill Ya.
So it be plenty of time.
You can be like it just a little worse.
Just a little worse.
It must feel amazing.
That's what I asked the cop.
It's only about it.
I was like,
how,
what's it feel like?
Awesome.
Right.
I mean it's making people have like rotten holes in their body where they're
shooting it in.
I mean,
it's really crazy to look at when we look at the images,
it just rots away your skin.
We talked about this on this pocket.
No,
we never have take this.
I don't know anybody who range,
man.
Hey Man,
I got just good shit.
It makes your skin fall off.
Well,
that's not the effect that they want.
Something I'll tell you about.
People are so crazy,
bro.
There's so crazy.
It's just such a weird animal.
Just the fact to know how much to take us down.
Yeah.
Well,
how about none?
That's the good move.
My friend told me he took mushrooms in Amsterdam and he didn't like him and I
was like,
oh,
well how much should you take?
Where'd you take him?
He goes,
I took 20 grams and I went to the,
I was like,
what?
Well,
that's why it's like drinking a fucking bottle of Tequila and saying,
I don't like booths.
20 grams.
Yeah.
It sounds like you're not a grams in a pound and a pound.
I Dunno.
An ounce is like,
oh,
that's different.
I don't know how many pounds.
Yeah,
it's at what,
two and a half ounces?
I think two and a half ounces in a pound.
Maybe.
I'm totally wrong.
I don't know how many grams.
20 grams would be about an ounce.
Would that be right?
One pound equals 453 grams.
Okay.
So we took 20 rooms.
Nowhere near a pound.
Yeah,
nowhere near it.
But still he imagined you a pound of mushrooms.
Oh my God.
Kill you.
What's the,
I wonder,
let's find out.
You would,
you might,
you might die from eating the same thing of any one food.
I think the last time,
the one time that I took it where I think I overdosed,
I think I came out to about a quarter in a like a,
an eight.
A quarter.
An eighth.
So one once I seen one,
eight,
two,
three,
eight,
eight Jesus.
He threw me off.
Yeah,
it took three days.
that's a lot.
What kind of mushrooms do you remember?
I don't know if the ones that look like fake.
I like Mario Brother Mushrooms.
Like the stamps were really big and the caps were like,
like ridiculously fun.
280 milligrams per kilogram for a rat killer rot.
200 what?
280 milligrams per kilogram.
Like,
I dunno how many kilos.
Erratic.
So how much killer,
how many killers am I?
Well,
the problem with all this LD 50 for rats.
There's a lot of shit that kills animals that doesn't kill us,
but there are also a lot of things to kill both rats and us and there's also a
lot of things like way more things.
Kill Rats,
but does kill us.
Kill us.
The fucking disgusting vcs.
They're really disgusting.
Date each other.
I've told this story before,
I killed a big ass rat,
my fucking garage and Encino killer with a trap and I'm just late at night.
It was like,
I heard it stop,
go off while I was writing and I went out and got it tomorrow I would got up in
the morning and there was nothing but skin,
a little bit of skin and a tail.
They ate that fucking rat.
We had a rather truth through its tail in order to get out.
Ooh.
Yeah.
This route was a big fucking rat to man.
They had some big hill rats up there in the Hollywood hills.
I got a real problem.
And from New York,
they're everywhere.
Yeah,
some dude was,
would you rather have mice or rats?
Mice.
Mice by a long shot and time that that one guy that we had on the shed,
the hoarder guy,
what's his face?
I can't even think of his name right now,
but we're looking at Matt.
He said that he would rather have rats
and Anthony,
yesterday,
a friend of mine lived in the Hollywood hills or his brother.
His friend lives in the Hollywood hills and they were,
uh,
he had to like a dope house with a theater,
but when they were watching the movies,
he goes,
when the movie comes on,
put your feet up.
Because sometimes rats run across the floor.
It's like,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
I get away.
Worst movie.
He goes,
if you live in the hills,
there's just no way to avoid them.
What could you imagine?
There's no way to avoid rats in your fucking house.
Like ants.
That's crazy though.
It's little animals.
Sedans.
Wow.
If you've seen new treatise of your single giant rats in the south.
Yeah.
They went David Tillman Nutrient Hunting Watson.
I found out about it out loud about it too was that was that show insomniac
while I was watching some show on the,
uh,
one of those outdoor channels I was hunting and there's the dude's a chef,
I think that's called dead meat or something like that.
That's the name of the show.
And uh,
he would go and he,
he'll shoot all kinds of weird things and cook them like all kinds of weird
animals.
And so they cook nutria.
They shot these nutrients,
but there's a balancing nutrients for every nutrient you kill.
They give you five bucks.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
I've ever make a living that way.
If you have a seven inch tail and you know,
they're,
they're big man.
There's a lot of them.
Do they attack people or they're just,
no,
they're vegetarians.
We just kill them.
The problem is they're,
they're destroying the wetlands.
They are there.
Their rate of erosion caused by nutrients.
Where does it come from?
Some insane amount.
It was like they came from another country,
350 yards or 350 acres a day.
They were killer roading.
Yeah.
These animals were eroding like an insane amount of ground they can cover in a
day and they're just jacking all these wetlands.
And so since they started this bounty on him,
the show said that they dropped it down to 50 acres a day.
But there's still,
there's still fucking things up.
I mean,
it's like the bigger is a lot to lose.
One day day,
they're just jacking these fucking,
all this wetlands,
they just kill all the vegetation and all these a swampy,
crazy areas.
They just kill all the vegetation there.
Huge.
The fucking thing was like a dog man and the,
this dude,
they went out and they shot him and like an hour's time,
they shot like six or seven of them and they throw him in the boat and they took
them back and cook them.
It was really weird,
man.
It was funny how everybody was like repulsed by it.
Like everybody that they told that it was a Nutria,
they like,
Ooh,
but if you tell somebody you got a pig,
like what is,
he wants Bacon.
It's like we came up with cool names for shit.
That's not the Atmel itself,
like beef.
Beef is cow,
you know,
Venison.
Venison is a,
a deer.
You know what I mean?
They would have to come.
You can't just say you're going to eat rat.
You can tell you I'm going to eat chicken.
Yeah.
Chicken us.
True chicken is only chicken.
Yeah.
But like pork is like Bacon.
Ham.
You can have,
you can have work.
Yeah.
You gotta have a couple of different names for it.
Vacant.
So fucking good.
So good.
It's so good.
Been at Denny's when they have bacon shit.
Oh yeah.
The fat and the crispy meat.
It's so delicious.
Shakes.
Yeah.
It's so delicious.
Dot.
I mean,
this has been talked to death by Comedians,
but the idea of,
uh,
it's become carts or almost like a joke.
Yeah.
Put Bacon on any kind of food.
It makes it better.
Yeah.
Chocolate and Bacon's good.
Have you ever had that too?
It's okay.
How did the fair ones?
Yeah.
I've had,
they put a little salt on it.
You know what's amazing man?
Salted Carmel.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
that shit's good.
I just feel like that's all stirred.
Yeah.
Salted caramel ice cream.
Holy Shit.
I know you're talking about,
there's a place in Denver too,
I forget the name of it,
but they have amazing salted caramel ice cream.
Sounds amazing.
And Denver's where arched fears going to be next week.
Recording fucking powerful pamphlets.
You see,
that's a segue son.
That's how he wants it on there.
The 10th through the 12th of May.
But I bought the cool people,
like all these people listening he wants.
So,
uh,
and by the way,
the comedy works,
you owe it to yourself.
If you're going to see a comic like Ari,
go to the best club in the FEC and country and the comedy works in Denver might
just be that club.
If it's not the best club,
guess what?
There's no better.
There's no better club than the comedy works in Denver and there's no better
club in,
in the planet.
There's just not,
there's the clubs that are just as good,
but there's no better cuts on any list of like,
these are the clubs I like to play before I stop.
The comedy works in Denver is it's at the level of the best club in the country.
I don't think there's any one best club in the country cause there's like,
like a helium and Philly that's the same level,
the same level.
There's no,
there's nothing bad about that club.
It's perfect.
That's the one of the best clubs in the country and the I,
in my opinion,
like helium and Philly and the comedy works in Denver.
They're the same level of club.
I think that that place is as good as it gets.
It's the,
it's the cream of the crop.
As far as comedy clubs go.
Denver is the stoniest coolest fucking city in the country.
I loved Denver.
Coming back to Columbus,
I'm going to,
yeah.
You know what?
I'm going to go from there.
I'm going to book that.
I'm booking a bunch of shit now that I have to write a bunch of new stuff,
so when it come to Columbus,
that's probably what I'll do.
I'll probably do the comedy club for a couple of times.
Yeah,
the funny bugs,
a good club there,
but isn't it weird having that place?
Doesn't have a green room.
It's like need them.
I kinda like it.
I like,
I like when you're roughing it.
Yeah.
I like when you have to live like that.
Sometimes it's realistic.
It's good.
It's good for you when you have to be in the hallway warming up and it's fucking
people walking by with drinks.
It seems stupid,
but I think,
I think all that stuff,
you should never get away from that,
that all that,
that,
that's a real comedy club,
man.
That's,
that's,
that's where we all cut our teeth.
That's where,
that's what's responsible for a lot of guys making a living.
Those kinds of clubs,
that's,
those are real places.
When you're there for two or three hours over it just nice to have a place to
put your stuff,
but you know what?
Just go out and sit with the people at the bar who gives a fuck.
Just go hang out with people.
That patio is so big that he should just put a shed out there or an error.
Steam.
What if you pulled up in one of those [inaudible] airstream trailer and every
bad ass patio because people can't smoke in the bars,
right?
Isn't that to get a lot of smoke,
isn't it?
The laws now.
Right,
so you have to go outside to smoke.
Yeah.
That's a that that law apparently is a big divider amongst the pool world.
Pool players have really upset.
Really?
Yeah,
because a lot of guys,
first of all,
when the gambling,
they would just constantly be smoking or had the same problem.
Yeah.
They tried to get it out.
There was the last link,
the leaf casinos.
The poker area.
Yeah.
I know him for that.
That deep breath that I just took,
that was like a lot of guys,
they need that.
They needed that.
They needed that cigarette to calm them down.
Whether gamble.
I don't think they needed it.
I think I just got used to it.
I know they're resisting change.
They're addicted and when they're addicted,
yeah,
you need it.
You know,
I,
I've seen a lot of guys who just got really pissed off and they would start
going to places that would allow smoking,
would let you chain smoke.
So it's like,
I've thought like going out,
I can't just keep going outside.
I just want to keep going.
The only way they can make that different is if you,
uh,
made it a private club.
Like I'm,
I belonged to a cigar club.
It's a very whole too schmaltzy me and my brother Matt.
And when we go,
we,
uh,
we can go and smoke cigars with always people like out in those plants in a food
and we act like assholes,
like big wigs,
you know,
like a deal maker.
I'm a deal breaker up here at 17 and it's kind of a crazy place cause it's,
the girls are all really pretty and they like scantily clad and they serve
excellent food.
And there's all these rich guys out there.
You always see him like movie stars and Shit,
but it's a club,
you know,
and you're allowed to,
you're allowed to smoke cigars at this club.
They should make a place where you know how many clubs?
What's that?
What?
I was going to say that.
What's that one?
Scared Toronto.
Oh No,
in Toronto?
Yeah.
Oh,
the one to here.
How's it shut it down.
The back room.
They get scared because I'm going to go,
when the shut downs was starting,
they were like,
we don't want to take any chances because people don't know how much we're
allowed to go away with,
so just guessing.
They were gonna shut down.
Times are like,
what?
Stop.
It was a hash mark.
It was so great.
Full Hash,
but people go there to write.
That guy came up to me a couple of times when we're doing sales and he asked me
to do shows there and I was like,
you're going to jail.
Really?
Like,
I'm like,
if everyone's in there with a car,
why does it matter?
Smoke there.
There's,
there's the possibility.
Always a federal federal intervention if the DEA is in town because they're
going to start cutting down there anyway.
They just have a regular pot room.
Yeah,
but not that word,
but that's where people are going to be getting high,
actually physically getting high and a lot of them,
I guarantee you are not going to be legal,
is going to be a lot of sneaky hippies.
That Mama didn't know the money to redeem that card.
What's the hassle?
It should totally be illegal anyway.
Men Nature gave me my license.
A few of those fuckers are gonna.
They're gonna arrest them.
You could be,
they're doing a show while that goes down.
You might go to jail too.
Every time I'm like,
I want to wait.
When your card has said we've got renewed,
let's say May 1st you're like ultra by bunch of weed,
April 29th and that'll last me til like June 30th.
Uh,
but then like,
what am I doing?
Well,
I was trying to buy two months for the fucking $45 it costs.
It is beautiful that you can just go to a store and buy it.
Yeah.
I really,
I said,
I don't think that's going to go away now just because of the fact that it's
changes to it.
Real gold now.
Yeah.
It has a big impact on the,
the economy.
It's just the rest of the country really doesn't know that kind of freedom yet.
They don't know how easy it is to live like this.
You know,
it's great.
And people who think there's anything wrong with it,
you're being silly.
It's drugs,
it's drugs.
Like that's not a good enough answer.
So it was alcohol.
So it was Adderall.
So it was,
that shows this coffee,
I'm drinking,
this is a drug,
my shit.
He's like,
yeah,
so what's a drug?
So is this an Uber ring I have in my trucks?
Trucks,
all you want,
what's the difference?
People are scared and Ari Shaffir there,
God damn scared.
They're scared of void.
Cigarettes have addictive nicotine him and did,
you shouldn't say like well just cause they're doing something wrong.
You should be allowed to,
but like we are going to have to.
So you know,
I was going to write this thing.
I wrote this whole thing about this,
this Trayvon Martin thing.
When that kid got shot and there was all these people are rallying one way or no
problems,
no one really knows what happened.
Exactly.
No one does know what happened,
but my,
my,
my feeling was like,
man,
when are we going to evolve past the point where that's even a concern.
Exactly what I'm going to evolve past the point where people were breaking into
people's houses and stealing shit.
When are we going to evolve past the point where people are starting shit with
people because they're packing a gun.
Is there ever going to come a time when that that's the past.
We were not hacking each other with swords in the streets every day.
Everywhere you live anymore,
everything has gotten radically improved.
Security and safety radically improved every city,
all over the world for animals here.
Yeah,
but I know when they said,
well,
they said they were in lines after the tsunami and the Japanese people were in
lines waiting to get their food.
It's so nice that you wait in lines here and they don't so orderly and he was
like,
well,
that's the only way it should be.
Yeah.
What are you talking about?
It's just we've become such animals that we think that's great.
Well,
we are a country without much history or tradition.
You know,
we have a sort of a fake history and traditional,
you know,
make a big deal out of our history.
You know what I'm aware,
again,
I know my history.
You know what history,
a bunch of marauders,
great grandfather started escapees from other countries at fucking came over
here and tortured and killed all the natives.
Or you came later and,
or,
yeah,
well you came late at my history.
You're white trash.
That's not a history.
It's silly when you stop and think about like say the history of China or the
history of Japan.
One Country that's been in one place for a thousands of years.
I mean there's a true history to Japan and there's a history of obedience and
there's a history of order and discipline and it's,
it's uh,
the tradition of it is far stronger than it is in this country.
That's a fact.
Brian and I saw it when we went over there.
And I'm not saying that if I had to choose between living in Japan and live in a
generic America Chimerica Jamiroquai
if I had to choose which child living in Japan or live in with Jamiroquai,
I would say I'm going to live in Japan because that would kill that dude.
You wouldn't want to have as a roommate.
Apparently he gets crazy.
I love his music though,
don't get me wrong.
But apparently he gets crazy and throws punches at people and Shit.
But um,
Japan was so much more polite and orderly and even like when we were at though,
they didn't understand
us.
So when we're at the arena,
once we got in and I showed them that I had a badge they'd like talked about and
I go,
now he's with me,
he's with me.
Like,
ah,
they just let you go,
let you go.
I don't like that.
At some point we were like,
look,
obviously you can lie to me if you want,
but don't please don't do that.
I'll just check.
Yeah,
it's,
there's a noticeable,
and I'm not saying it's a perfect society,
a utopia or anything like that,
but there's a notice belief up in inpatients in a noticeable leap up and
kindness and the way people interacted with people.
It was really interesting.
That's what happens.
We have unfettered access to a rape,
a ball,
Chinese women.
Is that what it is?
I fucking like just calm down,
just calm down and go right in London.
Then go back to calm.
I'm going to go back to Japan soon.
I think me and [inaudible].
Are you going to hit on a little vacation and thinking
they're going to get sexy?
Brad from stream has an office there,
so he goes all the time.
So it's picking.
Next time it goes,
I might just go with them and just a hangout.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well I,
I found it quite fascinating.
I mean,
I've been to several different countries now and it really does illuminate you.
You know,
Ari and I went to Brazil recently and we were sitting,
it was like seven o'clock in the morning.
We may or may not have just smoked some weed and we're sitting on this balcony
overlooking this beach and it's fun was coming a,
the sun's coming up and we're watching all these kids play and play soccer.
And we were like,
who does this in America?
It's 7:00 AM who does run out there and started playing soccer and the barefoot
crossing the street and these other kids got home from like going out.
But it was like they looked like they're hungry,
they're tired,
they're still out with her holding their shoes.
I don't think we're just out.
I don't think Brazil is better than America or Americas better than Brazil,
but I know that that way of living is better than the way that most people here
live.
I heard,
I heard a quote recently,
I think it was mark twain,
but Johnny [inaudible] had told me he goes up.
Um,
it was,
um,
comparison is the death of joy.
Wow.
It's like,
who cares what better or worse?
I'll just tell you what the nice things we saw.
That's beautiful.
Do you know in Japan that that government plays,
it pays your electricity.
They pay a lot of things that like one of those is going to change now that
they're power plants or fucking melting into the earth.
Right.
Or maybe they just started charging for and they could have a better profit to
make sure this doesn't happen in the future.
I wonder if that's even more profit on the,
what do you mean with that too?
They're fucked.
Brian there they have a real problem with those three reactors.
How could they be possibly a fourth?
How would the profits of salt,
the meltdown?
Well,
because obviously it seems like their shit was built like retarded style,
you know,
like they,
if they had like some more Pete,
like intelligent people going,
wait a second,
why are you should not build it.
So it only goes to a way to 6.0 or 7.0 magnitude quake.
They had it up to an 8.2 8.2 it was a even larger than that.
It was like a nine.
Why don't you make that Shit 20 you know?
Well,
I don't think they can't.
The real,
the reality is I just go deeper and yeah,
I've just seen,
we didn't we just talk about this the other day.
This is my take on,
um,
the,
the craziness of nuclear power was that it's
only been around for less than a hundred years.
And think about it in a hundred years.
All the different,
huge cataclysmic disasters from Chernobyl to a three mile island to this one and
Fukushima.
This is three giant,
huge ones that have taken place and they've,
oh,
it's only been in less than a hundred years.
How long is nuclear power?
Thank you sir.
How long has new clip powerful?
See Two.
Oh,
coconut water,
my favorite.
It's delicious.
It comes from Thailand.
Can't be it.
If it tastes so good,
you think that it's got sugar in it.
And I even asked him,
I know you got sugar in the ship bench.
They sell it on it.
Where were we before we went in the coconut room?
Nuclear.
The real issue is they don't know how to shut these fucking things off.
And that's terrifying.
It's terrifying that they,
they're willing to build something that they don't have an out clause with.
They were just hoping to keep the power on so they can cool.
Keep it cooled off.
They should have never really wants to be without nuclear power.
So to Sweden in 40 years,
yeah,
I think Norway has moved towards that as well.
There's been a couple European countries that are considering this now.
They realize,
first of all,
they're very small.
You know,
a lot of European countries.
Think about the impact of one nuclear power plant or two would have had on them
in Japan is very small and they're seeing,
they're seeing the impact of the radiation pretty far.
There's some kind of met this might,
this is O'Brien dumb shit thing,
isn't there some kind of
metal that they can almost as coke cover an entire reactor,
like,
like the shoe,
like pewter,
you're never going to feel it's too hot.
Everything's gonna melt in it.
Everything's going to be nuclear reacted.
It's,
I don't understand nuclear science enough to comment on it,
but what I understand,
they literally can't cool this thing off and they don't know what to do and
they're pouring ocean water on and try to cool off the reactors.
They've eaten through their containment.
They don't know where,
where it's going to go as far as like how much it's going to impact the soil.
They've never really had one meltdown like this before,
let alone three meltdown in one area.
In Japan,
they've never had this,
so they've got to learn from what happened in Chernobyl.
I don't know if Trenoble his damage was as bad as this one is,
but it's pretty fucking significant and this scary thing again is that there's
several of these things all over the place.
I shouldn't say several.
There's hundreds of moment of the world and if,
if these reactors keep fucking up different spots of the world,
we're going to have giant areas of our world that's contaminated in dead for
hundreds of thousands of years and that's the reality that we're operating under
and living under right now.
While you and I are sitting here talking on this laptop and you know our,
our information is being passed through the Internet.
There's lights that are on and you know,
and you're going to get in your car and you're going to go and electricity is
going to fucking power that gas meter.
When you pump gas at the gas station and there's going to be an electronic,
all that shit is nuclear power,
Sun.
All that shit is built on the back of insanity.
Our entire civilization runs on an insane idea that we're going to take and
we're going to make a nuclear reaction.
We're going to make a fucking reactor and we're going to use this insanely hot
thing to burn water and creates steam and
the steam is going to power and make electricity.
It's nuts.
It's fucking crazy.
And it's how the whole country works.
The whole is essentially almost primarily on coal and nuclear power.
So it's either giant fires or it's,
you know,
some people in mill,
there's a few places that have like windmill fields.
Yeah,
dams can generate some electricity,
but there's a lot of it that it's nuclear.
A lot.
You ever been to that windmill fields?
That's like right outside of Los Angeles going up like we went to Joshua tree at
night.
She's just thousands of these red dots.
Like I had no idea what it was and I'm just driving on what the fuck was that?
Holy Shit.
What is this?
It done a few fear factory.
That's cool.
And those,
those,
those fan things are so slim that you're like,
what?
How does this do anything small against steel cable.
Fucking wait Brian,
how does your brain work?
Where we were on a conversation about nuclear power and stuff and you asked
about the safety of nuclear power.
How would that be an O'Bryant moment?
We're completely staying on topic and not making it,
because I was talking about pouring metal on top of a whole factory,
locking it down in a big metal box.
Little toys used to buy when you're a kid,
like does it look cuter?
Toys like whatever,
whatever that is.
If you poured like a billion gallons of oil,
I think the real issue is you see they can't cool it down.
It's going to take forever to come up.
How's other nuclear plants cool down the power to cool it down?
A lot of what's going on in a nuclear power plant is keeping it stable and
making sure that there's not what's called a meltdown,
and I don't understand it enough to be just talking in vague terms,
but what happened with Fukushima was the earthquake and tsunami and flooding and
everything fucked up their backup generator,
so they had nothing,
they had nothing to keep it powered,
so they had essentially eight hours before there was a meltdown,
so there's eight hours where they could just evacuate the area,
and I don't know,
but I'm sure,
I mean there's Bonnie's that had been born with no ears is weird mutants that
are starting to hear in the apple world,
the fish things,
they're just hanging out with visibility.
Nonworking eyes just hanging out front with me and Joe,
you probably have whatever we have now in Japan.
That's like four.
I was going to not eat the Sushi over there,
but it looks so delicious.
I was like,
whatever.
Let's let it rock.
Yeah.
That lasted a half hour.
I think.
We were talking about how we weren't going to eat anything.
I'll just have 12 Sushi.
Great.
And everybody looked healthy.
That's not how cancer has.
No,
look,
we're a,
we were just talking to you and I were about mad cow.
They just found an episode of Tau.
Yeah.
Then they said the only reason I found it is cause they random testing.
She's just didn't have,
didn't have the,
the symptoms at all.
He wasn't irritable.
Yeah.
No,
but they said they ha they act a certain way.
Dude,
it's so scary.
They're feeding cows,
cows mad cow disease comes from them taking cows and then butchering them and
then grinding up their brain matter and all sorts of shit and using it for
protein that they
feed the other cows.
I'm mixing them with the grants and cows aren't supposed to eat cows by the way.
So why are they doing this?
Really just to save money.
Yes,
exactly.
To save money because it makes us more effective feed.
You can force the cows to eat that shit and they will eat it and stay alive and
they get all fat fucked up and they get essentially what's called Jacob's
crutchfields disease,
which is the same disease that savages and cannibals in New Guinea get where
they got the shakes.
They get this terrible neurological disorder from eating human brain because
your program can not eat.
Not supposed to eat that up.
Exactly.
It's a fucking trick by nature to make sure the cannibals don't survive.
A lion ate human Brian.
He no problem.
No problem.
Unless the lion ate a human who had Jacob's Creutzfeldt disease,
he could get it because he could get it from what are called prions and that's
the concern with people eating beef that came from England during a certain
period of time when mad cow disease was running rampant.
The idea is that you could have possibly gotten this.
Jacobs had people starts showing symptoms that ever,
sorry,
glove.
Yeah,
sure.
People die from mad cow disease.
And then the joke,
the prime minister of England was trying to say,
remember that was trying to say it's safe now switch that a burger to his
daughter.
She's,
this is how say how thick it is.
Christ.
That's crazy.
That's game of Thrones type shit.
Crazy asshole.
It's,
you know,
it's amazing that there are so greedy and Stinky and disgusting that they've
actually decided that there's a good way to save money.
Feed cows,
cows.
You know what I mean?
It's just a conti decision.
Just the worst decision when any company that makes that decision,
the government should come in like storm troopers and closed their fucking shop
down and make it a socialist place.
It should take over and feed the cows.
Only grass burger cans going to 'em.
That's how bad I feel about it.
To 'em safe chickens and something else and like like 2017 safe chickens,
free range range chance.
That's awesome.
So those are more expensive but maybe,
maybe they're just like financials a little more on it won't make as much
definitions of free range.
I better pretty sloppy.
But free range is that they don't,
they're not in cages.
They're in a giant pit.
That's probably what it is.
We're just looks like it's moving.
Yeah,
that's free range by the way.
I forgot her and look through the screen door.
The cats move all at once.
Sometimes it just looks like the floor is moving.
It looks like they're migrating to Diaz.
Is living in Iraq?
Like birds?
Yeah,
it's like 12 it's like a bunch of them have 12 now.
I think it's something like that.
I think an idea cause I went,
I need to get rid of one of my cats because it just doesn't work well with my
dog and the other cat hates it too,
so it's just miserable.
So I want to find like an old lady to give it to them.
But I was thinking about just like taking it over to his house and just kind of
like throwing it into the mix.
Why don't you pawn it off on my ex girlfriends they've had,
they've pawned off dogs and cats on you.
Yeah,
I should know that's,
that's an old cat.
What about that's what grandmothers are foreign.
But unfortunately all my grandmothers are dead.
But I used to always give them my cat like a dictionary and just slam that skull
giving you their cats.
Folk
people need animals.
Yeah.
I think companionship is fucking for sure.
If anyone in Los Angeles is old and needs a companion,
take your old Cathy,
you're hot shit.
He'll call me and then I'll see how as long as I can to live your hope it dies,
right?
I think it's like six more years if you come up going,
no you're not.
What do you ever hope he dies?
Uh,
I don't hope any animal dies,
but it's sort of,
do you want to be upset?
Is miserable cat right now and I feel really shitty for,
for even trying to give it a happy life right now.
Why is it so miserable?
Because you've got a second cat.
Cause I have a second cat and a dog and both of them fuck with those two.
Love each other and they're like a gang and they were just like,
fuck this other cat.
The other cats,
they original original line.
And it's like damn bed.
You've created a gang war in your own house.
Your bullies in your own house.
Yeah.
It really,
while you're supposed to get rid of the Ode to supposed to get rid of the cat
and the dog.
Yeah,
but they pay me the original.
They pay you or pay me off cause it was a new attention.
Yeah.
You need that now.
I know that's my poop.
So he never poops on and in the in the house because he just eats it right away.
A clean it up.
Don't ask him because it's going to be something like this.
He picks up after himself,
he shits and then eats it back up.
I never
thought so discussing.
Yeah,
but he ended up saying poop up off the floor.
It's just like you just like,
are you joking around right now?
I hope you are not.
You leave that thing in and it doesn't have it can't shit so just shits on the
ground poop pad and it needs its own shit.
Huh?
Indeed Sasha,
it loves its own shit.
Shit.
A peed of a dog but does not eat.
It's a lot like all of it or just look at it.
You want to look at it or is it all of it?
Every time I come down and it looks like he ate a nice cookie,
there's little crumbs of his own dude.
How?
How was not?
Not Incredibly disgusting to you because I haven't gone out of his mouth.
I put Listerine strips in his mouth and I don't.
I put no,
I have to stop.
I have this dog spray stuff for dog breath or we saved this conversation.
Are you addition processor?
If I can't allegedly allegedly apps to find out where I am,
what part of the world,
if I do Mondays for just for Comedians,
when I block out of an amount of time like that,
it's very selfish because I'm a father.
I could smoke pot and be functional,
but I have to be real particular about like where I,
where I do shrooms
work.
I tell you the last time I did it,
man,
I was convinced I'm never going to do this shit ever again.
Well,
I've done it since I was a young person and then I stopped for seven years and
then I always thought in that seven year time I'm like,
you know what?
I've done everything I needed to do at that.
That's stupid.
Now I need.
But then I started dating younger girls and then I had to re go through all
their drug experiences and now I'm back into how I was when I was 21 again,
I think it's,
uh,
it's
all about the intent.
Like what are you trying to accomplish that are using it or you're trying to
find something out about yourself.
Are you trying to have like a spiritual journey that you go on or are you just
trying to play and party and get fucked up and say,
oh,
I can't believe what I took?
Well,
I took so much because I think a lot of times when you do that and he don't go
into a trip like you can,
you could take a mushroom trip for granted and a mushroom trip can kick your
fucking ass.
Yeah.
I think it'd be just fun too though.
Sure.
If you're an old state,
go to like a concert.
The quantity,
quantity,
UAA food,
how much food you ate,
the quantity and who you're with,
where your state of mind you want to be with people you love.
Yeah.
And you can get away with doing mushrooms,
but the,
when you do big doses like you did,
you did a giant dose.
I firmly believe that you should last time,
be prepared for a fucking journey through space.
When you do that,
I mean,
you should be someone who's been going to yoga class.
You should be selling anything.
Sit down.
I think that's,
I think that's an overdose on mountain like,
well,
there is such thing as overdose amount,
meaning
the rats,
the body immediately rejects any of it.
Like a small amount.
That's what an overdose.
It's like your body is like,
no,
no.
Get this out of an overdose.
You're reacting to that,
to that stuff.
This thing about mushrooms is it's not poison.
It's what's going to,
Jackie was like,
it's like saying salt as poison.
Salt doesn't poison,
but if you had a pound of it,
you're fucking dead.
It's the warm,
yeah.
Mushrooms are the,
the,
the act of psychoactive ingredients and mushrooms.
They,
it mimics human neuro chemistry.
That's why it's so powerful with mushrooms is,
is like for,
with silicide bananas,
I don't know how to say it exactly,
but something like four phosphoryl,
oxy and,
and dimethyltryptamine and dimethyltryptamine is actually made by the human
brain.
So it's die methyl trip to me and plus something else.
And it's some weird phosphorus something or another molecule attached to it
somehow or another that makes it different.
But whatever it is,
it's so close to human neuro chemistry.
It's not really a poison.
It's just some weird fucking side venture that you can take your mind on.
So the danger is only in like spectacular doses to,
to actually worry about poisoning yourself to the three grams are fine.
Yeah.
You could take,
you could take a lot.
I mean,
I know many people that the five and 10 grams,
I've heard two grams from many different people and they are fine.
I mean,
there's scared as fuck.
And when they come out of it,
I mean they shot through the middle of the fucking rabbit hole and came back
with Robert Lewis cat.
What does,
what does the guys about what you did?
10 grams.
That's about 10 groups.
Yeah.
Robert Louis Stevenson.
Is he the one who wrote um,
Alice in wonderland,
which she wrote with this.
Let's just go with it.
Cause it wasn't like Lewis Carroll though,
isn't it?
Was Carol's Carol Lewis Carroll multiply that times a middle ship.
I mean all that stuff was,
that was all psychedelic inspired.
I'm sure all of his,
I mean it wasn't it supposed to be about assets supposed to be about that.
Yeah,
you could,
you could take enough mushrooms that you could fucking lose your mind for sure.
I'm just super,
super hot.
No one has listening to this is going
to take that much.
I,
my legs do not work.
I fell to the ground.
Legs don't work.
I thought as he's walking down the street,
my legs didn't work.
I mean like I fell to the ground and I could not stand up.
It's not a good example for the youth of America.
No,
and I don't think that's anything that is,
people should try it unless they done the research and make sure they're safe.
And I was talking about age.
What's that?
That was 10 grams.
That was that.
That was when I took a quarter in an eighth.
Whatever that is.
Whoa.
The youth of America.
And they deserve better than that.
Brian,
you're a leader at this point.
I think you need to step up.
I'll have it on here.
Don't do it.
Stop having your legs fall apart,
son.
How many grams you think you did?
What you had this spectacular trip?
10.
It's [inaudible].
That's what it comes out to.
10,
10 to 11.
10 to 11 grounds.
So crazy.
What was the most memorable part of it?
Uh,
my hand turning into pyramids.
Gold Pyramids.
Wow.
Nice.
Uh,
when I puked it was all colors and it turned into trees and it like felt like
there was trees going in my mouth and stuff.
And then three is going into your mouth.
The wow.
The walls are made it like at a Lego's and they were just falling down and wow.
It was fucking crazy.
I know it's sick.
I now,
what thoughts did you have?
All this was going on.
Uh,
olive garden.
I ate too much.
I would poison.
Why aren't my legs working?
I'm puking.
Here's what I tell.
I wasn't really paranoid.
It was more like something I've never had my legs never work.
I've never had bought,
like I've trimmed off 100 times plus and I've never had it where like my body
wouldn't work.
So you were just so bunkered out that you literally couldn't figure out how to
use things I guess.
I mean I,
I I recorded myself and I talked like I was fine and,
and uh,
and I,
I felt like I knew what was going on,
but it was more of like,
I felt like a poisoned.
What's like the best thing you ever learned from a trip?
What does,
what have you ever come out of a trip and had like this is like a real solid
revelation.
I always have revelations every single time.
Like the last one I did,
um,
which was,
uh,
I did an a shitty hotel room and I did a whole podcast with the other girl I did
it with and it's on death squad,
but I will help people find it.
Uh,
it's just go there and type in,
um,
it's on the front page of death squad.tv and it's like,
but for now,
people that people might be listening to this a hundred years from now.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'll tell you in a sec.
One Toe.
I doubt it,
but uh,
hopefully it sounds something cooler than I phones or Ipods,
but quite,
I did it with my,
her name,
what's her name?
I did it with my,
a friend friend Pamela Wall and Emmy Hawthorne.
And we just went to this really,
really,
really shitty hotel in a really scary place.
What's the name of it?
A motel six.
No,
may mean the podcasts.
I just
wanna look at that.
I would advise against,
by the way,
I could go into a place that's like a shitty environment.
Death Squad number 18.
And so then who are the people on it?
It's just me and Pamela Walt just did the,
we did our,
cause she had,
it was her first time doing mushrooms and she,
you know,
had got,
just got over having cancer and Oh crotch.
And she's homeless,
you know,
she,
she goes from couch to couch,
you know,
she just has had so much,
most of her life.
She had such bad s uh,
social anxiety that she would never even talk to anyone.
And then recently she started getting better with the help of actually had
Adderall it,
believe it or not.
Well,
uh,
and uh,
so now she's actually being able to function and talk to people,
which is something that she,
it's like being reborn as an adult.
Um,
she had the most fabulous,
wonderful time.
She,
she found all this things and it was just the most ideal thing ever.
And it's like in a Shitty,
shitty,
shitty situation.
Amazing how the same stuff,
the same batch of the same drug.
It's not like you've got a bad batch.
Just some people have a good trip and every once in a while somebody is a bad
trip.
I think a lot of it is going,
what's going on in your head?
Because there's with people in times in my life where I was teetering on a bad
state of mind,
but if you listen to the thing,
if there was a reason I was forced into this bad situation because I went from
being like all right this like we might get shot at this hotel,
this hotel is actually a place that you'd go to do drugs and get hookers.
Like there's people living there and we explain this whole thing in detail.
So I ate it and then immediately started realizing like,
wait a second,
we don't want to be here for six hours trapped in this room.
I need to be a babysitter because this might be really bad at something like
fear and loathing in the middle of the desert type shit.
That's funny dude.
You should to write about that and that should be part of your act on stage.
I need to figure it out.
That's a funny idea for a bit,
dude.
Getting fucked up on mushrooms in the wrong hotel.
It was bad cause like every time I wanted it to go have a cigarette,
I had to go outside.
And one time there was like this black dude that right there was like running
really fast.
Then he hid behind a wall and you look out and he looked right at me.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
I saw him.
And then he started running as fast as he can.
Like he was absolutely hiding from something neighborhood was uh,
it was in this weird place in Ventura.
It was really bad.
Maybe he was on mushrooms maybe,
but,
but uh,
but I would go out and have a cigarette and I started like I had this a cell
phone case.
It had all these little diamonds on it,
kind of like these little gems self yet be dazzled.
And so I started like leaving them everywhere.
I would walk just so I would have a place if they have to find me.
There was like I was doing read their mind can definitely want her to on a bad
situation where it makes it seem way worse while you're mushroom.
And then there was a fire alarm outside of our door and I'm like,
that's the emergency thing.
If anything happens,
if we get robbed or stuff,
it's something I'm pulling that that's how scary this hotel was,
but I made myself puke but it was too late.
I would think it'd be so fun if you grab that and pull it and it's silence.
No,
it just falls off.
There's drugs and the claim
cooking happens on us,
but you got to do that within the first 30 minutes.
I tried to and it was the only time I've never heard a tripping out 30 minutes
in that heart.
I hadn't eaten the whole day or the night before.
I actually had my finger down my throat and never have done that successfully in
my whole entire life and made myself puke it up.
I got to pee and I start tripping.
How long into this was,
it was about 30 minutes.
If you've just started shipping afterwards,
why did you make yourself throw up?
No,
it was happening while I was puking.
I saw that stuff where you started feeling like terrible and stuff was happening
before.
Like as you sort of just was a different,
this is my latest trip.
We went,
I turned to my hotel room,
I just win after I ate,
I started noticing like how bad his hotel was.
Like we opened up the sheets and there was like a fucking mess shit in there and
there was like a stain that was on each side of the sheets and and yeah.
And then just people offside that were like,
it was scary.
Like the cops came at one point in the busted up.
This huge cops are good to see when you're on mushrooms even though they can't
tell,
they don't know anything.
They just still like good cops.
This is weird.
This makes a bad thing.
When Pam was checking into the hotel,
somebody crashed through the office in their car.
Why don't you go to there?
Uh,
I didn't go there.
I met them there and then I ran up to the room thinking oh this is cool.
And then right after I eat cause I was trying to catch up cause they were
already,
somebody crashed through the window with their car when they checked in to
somebody crashed the car into the office.
So like the wall was broken open and like,
Oh yeah and you'll look dumb.
Okay,
here's my credit card information.
This is,
I didn't do it.
But yeah it was,
it was uh,
it was a showroom of hell April while she was having the same exact opposite.
So it's interesting.
We just talked for like two hours about you can let yourself get in a bad place.
My friend took it once with a girl with a god he's barely knew and a girl he
sort of liked and it was just one of the worst trips for him because he said it
was like he was worried about his behavior in front of certain people and not
worrying puts you in a bad position.
Yeah.
That's one of the things about ecstasy.
That's so cool.
You can do it with anybody or you just feel like you'd like everybody.
Yeah.
Released everything.
I still think that's the best drag in the whole entire ride.
I had to choose one drug other than weed.
Yeah.
Like I said,
I love the experience with the comedown was fucking brutal.
It was brutal.
I took two pills.
I don't know what the milligrams,
where I am today.
The next day I was wrecked.
All sort of the same milligrams.
Right.
They're just different.
I seen the guy once,
I'm going to take nine.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
Yeah,
those are the same people that like long time ago when police do acid and they'd
be like,
dude,
I just did 12 hits of acid.
I'm like,
why would you do well there's,
there's certain dudes like James Cameron and want to go to the bottom of the
ocean.
See,
this guy wants to just go,
so some dudes just want to go to the bottom.
I saw one of these,
UFC is one of talks to
some pop pills or something and there was one colleague rude was fighting.
I got so fucking into it
on the floor areas.
We figured this out later,
like years later there was,
we went to a UFC once and he was so emotional and like screaming as long as mom.
And then he told me just like a couple months ago goes,
oh yeah,
I never told you this,
but I was on whatever you just said.
This is a good pop pills.
Best Mari now are a Ufo.
Ari,
a UFC moment is documented.
It's when,
uh,
um,
what the fuck is his name?
It was a in Brazil,
in Brazil.
Oh God.
That was Edom.
Got Wheel kicked in the head by Edson Barboza.
Edson Barboza cracked him with this wheel kick and as he's going down you and
Joe Silva right there and you like put your hands on your head like,
Holy Shit fucked my head up my mouth.
Like,
oh no,
that's so brutal.
Ari was like right over my right shoulder.
Like where I'm sitting,
I'm sitting like right at the cage and Ari's right behind me.
So if you look at like the animated gifs are online,
you can see are we pop up as a super slow motion.
When I thought it was like really cool to see it happening super slowly,
slowly up before he hits the ground.
I don't care what anybody says.
Dad is the greatest job I have ever figured out how to,
I don't know how the fuck I ever got a job working for the UFC.
But that is the greatest job ever.
It's so crazy.
Nuts.
Brazil was insane to be able to be there right there.
Ringside.
I've seen like,
like more than a thousand.
Great fights like that.
It's really incredible.
You know?
And then for you in Brazil,
you were right there with me and the stage 18,000 people fucking screen.
And you've never seen a crowd like a Brazilian crowd,
man.
Anybody who thinks that American crowds are loyal or no,
just screaming.
Usa Boxing Guy Trains in England.
Who's cream?
USA to the other one.
Yeah,
we scream USA.
But that's about it.
And in Brazil they scream,
you're going to die.
You're gonna die.
And then when Mike Pyle,
Mike Pyle won his fight against this Brazilian dude,
only numbers Brazilian or one against Funche.
And when he won,
the fucking whole crown is calling him a fag crowd Portuguese there to the,
to the,
to the translator.
Like what are they saying?
What are they selling right now?
But she thought they were saying a different word.
It turns out there were,
she thought they were saying she gone know which is junior dos Santos,
his nickname.
They were saying it's like fig I know or something along those lines which just
faggot.
It's unfortunate that Anderson Silva and Chael Sonnen and aren't going to be
fighting in Brazil.
There was apparently we're going to do it at the giant soccer stadium,
which is going to be 80,000 people.
But there was a UN meeting that was going on there the two days before.
So there would've been no hotel rooms.
It would have been a nightmare because you'd have to bring in 80,000 people from
other parts of Brazil in the world want to come in and fly in to see that fight.
So it was way too nutty.
So they had decided to move it to another place.
I would have been.
Cause it's the biggest fight available.
So just the biggest fight and it would be in the biggest city.
So it'd be like,
oh,
I think as far as what I've read is that they're still going to do a fight in
Brazil that week,
but they're,
they're locking down where that's going to be and who's going to be on that
card,
you know?
But the sheriffs are really great.
Anderson Silva and Max is going to be in Vegas,
which probably for Chell son in his fucking way better,
man.
That guy was,
he was in danger and danger.
I don't know.
That place was so goddamn beautiful.
Brazil.
It's amazing.
What Ari and I were saying is we were up at seven o'clock in the morning and
watching these kids playing and we're like,
look how great this life is.
Like,
why don't kids in America do this?
Why isn't everybody running around and playing like this?
Like this is like they were so,
it looks so joyful.
There was so much fun too.
And you knew that they probably were pulling like America used to be,
or at least is it still looking in the Midwest and stuff or just small towns
where you just get up and go play with people?
I don't know what I mean,
what makes a place like Brazil?
Is it just the environment,
the environment,
so beautiful.
The weather's so beautiful there on the ocean.
Ocean peep dwelling.
People almost always have like a certain appreciation and respect for the ocean.
Almost like a pre,
a little,
a little appreciation for nature.
That's why beach towns are always so calm.
You know?
There's like almost like a chilled,
relaxed thing.
It's like,
man,
you're just faced with something so impossible.
You're looking out at fucking a hundred trillion gallons of water or whatever
the fuck the ocean is where it's never ending.
You don't see the end of the water.
It goes bigger than the entire continent that you're living on and just it's,
it's so humbling.
It's just one of those things that you look at it.
It just,
it makes you chill out a lot of a people,
but you have to have a higher power that would make you have a higher power.
But some people don't want to say God,
so they can tell you.
It's like the ocean,
just me.
More powerful than you are.
Ooh,
I like that.
You know,
it sounds like led Zeppelin song too.
Damp,
damp towel.
Now
digital is still number one.
And then we want to get Doug Benson dethrone him for a little bit and then back
just back and forth.
Well,
Doug Benson is not a comedy album.
It's just a podcast.
You know,
he puts his podcasts up for sale.
Oh,
nice.
Yeah.
A lot of guys do that.
There's a lot of controversy about that.
Some guys have like one a month that they'll have for sale.
It's a big giant thing.
It's like whatever.
Yeah.
Um,
wow.
So He's back there.
Georgia is on my podcast this week on the skeptic tank.
Yeah.
Hey Joe,
you having fun with it?
I like it.
Do you want one a week?
Yeah.
Sometimes I'll get a couple in a week or two or three in a week if I'm gonna be
out of town a lot you want me to do or anything like that.
Consistently.
Really amazed.
How about us?
The fuck man.
I'm amazed we're doing it too.
What does episodes us to 11 or something like that.
It's crazy.
It's so you can,
at any point,
you could just be like,
I'm not going to do it anymore and it'll just be done.
There'll be no trouble.
Yeah.
It would be a problem with getting fired.
I think at this point in time we have a commitment.
Yeah.
I don't think we would be able to stop and go.
It's impossible.
There's too many people because I like nothing's really pushing you on.
There's nothing real there.
Yeah.
We all desire to keep doing it.
We owe people,
they've listened.
They've weighed our life better because they liked this podcast and I think we
owe them that.
People go to so many more comedy shows.
We're not going to stop.
Did I think it's in general?
Not just with this podcast,
but in general.
It started this renaissance of standup comedy.
Yes.
I go around the country and it's like,
and I see the clubs,
the like hometown club.
It's just more people that are out.
Yeah.
People have access to this art form they'd never had before and there's no more
good guy.
Yeah.
You can just find who your aesthetically pleasing person is.
You know,
Max dices kid went up at the ice house the other night,
did create on the podcast and went up and killed at the comedy show him like I
just,
I can't see enough of that.
I can't see enough of like this new generation coming in.
They're good.
I can't see enough of that.
Yeah.
It's so inspiring.
It's beautiful and podcasts are allowing these kids to sort of get their stage.
I'm telling you,
man,
that's one of the reasons why the Atlanta show went so well.
I'm so used to talking in front of people.
That's got to be a lot of it too.
I wrote down the podcasting is like cross training for stand up.
It is like not full job.
It's just training,
thinking and stuff.
It's like it gets you in shape for stand up.
Yeah.
I could never have gone up on that.
Just doing that.
Whatever quick set.
If it wasn't for a guys I would have fucked said fuck you and like shit myself.
You Know Eddie Bravo is going to do some dates with us.
He's going to emcee some shows.
Nice.
Any problem at once?
You want to go on stage?
He wants to MC,
he wants to bring people up.
It's got a lot starter.
He goes,
I,
I might,
I might try to do a joke or two here and there.
I'm like,
you can do it.
Like of course you can do it.
Anyone,
but if he doesn't want it,
they're just like,
he's what?
He wants to encourage them,
encourage them on Twitter for me.
Awesome.
Cause he can do it.
Eddie Bravo is one of the funniest dudes I've ever met.
I have to bring them up.
It's all about for him it would just be about focusing.
It would just be about him finding,
you know what?
Whatever it is that he thinks is funny and focusing.
See,
I know you're just scratching your beard,
but it looks like you're totally shaking your head when you're doing,
but I just want to straighten that out with all the internet.
Detective Brian has got it on his face,
but you don't see that because the microphone balls in the face,
so it totally looked like you were shaking your head.
It's just crazy.
Itchy eye.
That was definitely an itch.
Sorry,
I just started going back to Jujitsu again.
I took three months off.
I don't want your bulk up to get fat.
No,
I heard,
no,
I didn't,
didn't do anything.
I stayed the same way.
I kept training.
I made sure I kept working out.
I stayed in shape.
I stayed in,
um,
like kettle bell shape and weight lifting shape and workout shape.
But that's less than just the shape.
It's not good as Jujitsu's shape.
[inaudible] harder.
Wow.
I found myself struggling for the first couple of classes,
but not nearly as much as I'd be if I didn't do anything.
If I didn't do anything,
I wouldn't be able to do it.
We're literally wouldn't cause one of the things that I thought about while I
was working out why take took the time off.
That was when I was training.
I was working,
I was training to go back and roll.
Like I knew I did not want to get tired.
Yeah.
I did not want to get tired.
I was doing a lot of sprints.
It was doing a lot of,
um,
especially on the elliptical.
I do.
These things were just purely for cardio purposes.
I would do maybe 10 to 15 minutes as a warmup at a reasonable pace.
And then I would set it fairly stiff,
like level 13 or 14 maybe 15 minutes.
And then I would know I would blitzkrieg for 30 seconds,
just as hard as I can do it for 30 seconds and then kick it back and recover for
30 seconds and then do it again.
And I did it for 20 minutes.
So essentially 10 20 sprints,
20 mad crazy sprints when I lost all that way.
That's what I used to do.
The elliptical.
I would go as hard as I could for a minute and then do three minutes of just,
just kind of sitting there with my heart rate really high up and then it's so
hard,
man.
It's such a great workout.
I mean like when someone tells you you can't get a good workout on an elliptical
machine,
like,
bitch,
you're crazy.
I go when I'm in hotel rooms,
if I'm staying in a hotel and they say,
oh,
all they have is an elliptical machine,
I can get a fucking ferocious cardio workout in on an elliptical machine.
Yeah,
you just got to use it the right way.
And the beautiful thing is you don't get injured on those.
You don't,
you're not going to hurt your knees or yeah,
no impact.
It's all circular motions.
You did too.
So did Eddie Bravo,
some sort of a meniscus thing have happened to you?
I think he's a cartilage cartilage.
My other name,
the other name you play in basketball still?
No,
no,
no.
I'm not.
I can't do those bodywork.
Bodyweight squats that I,
I know I showed those.
Those are like literally miracle workers for strengthening and tightening your
knees.
One of the best exercises I've ever had for a leg endurance and for a building
up the muscles in the years I just standing up,
I took my shoes off after basketball.
I stood up and I just felt the pop fluid.
Well,
can they fix it?
When they say he's got to say exactly what it is first,
that's like a doctor to the other one that really,
he's really,
uh,
no,
that's the pot doctor.
Oh,
whoops.
get a little bit.
I know my doctors or my doctor.
Yeah,
he's a real doctor.
He worked on my knee two times.
He fixed my right knee and he fixed the meniscus in my left knee.
He fixed my left knee when everybody else had fucked it up or the other guy had
fucked it up.
The other guy,
he did want to scope it and he tried to stitch it up and it just never really
healed.
It was always amazing how when you think about it,
you'd think like,
doctors know what they're doing,
but like some doctors are bad.
You need doctors that work with athletes.
That's what you need because one of the things that happened after I got an MRI
when I tore my meniscus,
which is a really simple thing,
the meniscus is not that big of a deal out of the scope,
the rest over.
But the doctor is sitting there telling me I need to stop doing martial arts.
By the way,
this is the only,
I was only 30 at the time,
you know,
and the doctor's telling me you need to stop doing martial arts and I'm
listening to her and I'm going,
first of all,
why am I,
why are you telling me I'm not asking you for this,
let me go,
I don't see where this is like that big of an issue.
And she's like,
you're going to continue to injure this knee or you're telling me that it's
impossible to rehabilitate a meniscus tear and get my body to a condition where
I can train again.
I call shenanigans.
Okay.
Just because you,
you know,
you say you'd rather not have that,
but like what bitch,
what are you talking about?
I've been stitched up together like 15 fucking times.
I know what I'm doing.
I'm going to get stolen to deal with.
It was like,
oh no it was with some of weird,
she was being my mom.
Do you think,
do you think it's going to catch up like say 30 years from now?
No,
no.
I have no,
no pain man suit.
First of all I make sure I stretch out like crazy.
Okay.
Second of all,
I eat a lot of fish oil.
I take like 10,000 milligrams official a day.
I think that alone promotes like healthy strong joints and second of all I
stretching and doing all these body weight exercises.
Really important for strengthening up the joints and tightening those bodyweight
squats.
You go all the way down your ass touches your heel and your heel comes off the
ground and you push up from there and when you do like hundreds of those right
at the knee is where you build all your muscle.
Like all up in here,
like the flip cap of the quads and all around your knee.
All that builds up cause it's like a really high volume.
You know,
you're doing like 200 of them and it really tightens and strengthens everything.
It gives you more endurance in it.
Also because of the fact that your legs have done so much more work and they're
stronger,
you're less likely to have them buckle on you.
They're less likely to give out all car literally though muscle control.
Exactly.
That's a lot of the reasons why people get injured is because they don't have
enough physical strength to stop the injury from taking place.
Their body,
you know,
they're,
they're the coordination or they're exhausted or old people fall and break their
muscles cause there's nothing.
No fucking
broke.
The bones cause no muscles.
The guard gives that too.
Well also their bones get really fragile.
That's one of the things that osteoporosis,
they,
they uh,
if you're not lifting weights are taking care of,
uh,
your,
your body in that way where you're adding,
you know,
it's really important,
especially as you get older to actually physically lift weights.
If you want to keep your bone density bone,
your bone density.
Yeah,
it's very important there.
There's old dudes like you can go to the gym and there was a guy named Albert
Beckels and I believe he was in his late fifties or sixties Bryant,
Google that guy for me,
please.
Albert Beckels and Albert Beckels bodybuilder.
And he was really old man.
And I went to the gym.
There was a gold's gym in north Hollywood when I lived in north Hollywood.
And I used to see him training.
They're like,
Charles Atlas,
just be a man.
He was all as fuck dude.
And he was so,
Whoa,
like a motherfucker.
Look out the photos of that guy.
I mean,
he's kind of really nice asshole.
Um,
uh,
what was the other guy's name?
But,
oh,
look at this photo of this guy.
See if you can get a nice big one.
That's him.
He's black.
Like,
uh,
yeah dude.
I mean right there.
And he's probably like fucking 60 years old or something.
And I'm not kidding.
The guy was fucking enormous.
Just don't that a picture of his bicep.
That's his bicep.
Just pick,
just click on one picture.
So Ra can get us,
there's a good picture of him.
He's bald and old shit,
and just
look at the body on that guy's ridiculous.
Fuck there's this would be,
that's the only way you can do that.
We'll start Roy.
But the other way is you,
you have to lift weights in order to keep that density up at that age.
That keeps your bones,
your muscles,
your bones,
weightlifting,
especially like real heavy weight exercises like dead lifts and squats.
They contribute to thicker bone density.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's really important as you get older,
especially because that's when your bones start to get brittle and fragile.
So guys like Albert Beckels.
I bet that guy's like,
look at that guy's body and that's an,
he's in his fifties there,
dude.
I mean,
he was just the animal.
There's,
there's certainly dudes like that.
Yeah.
By the way,
orange but,
but also intense workouts and intense training and focus you,
you can't just give it all the steroids there because the guy still had to do
the work.
The steroids if he took,
yeah,
if he just took steroids only,
he would still never get that big.
Those guys have,
I'll never be that lean,
you know?
I mean you have to be incredibly dedicated to get down to that level.
And he's like championship bodybuilder level.
But the difference between a guy like them or a guy like say Steve Maxwell,
Steve Maxwell is a guy who was 100% natural and he's a fitness fanatic and he
is,
I believe he's about 60.
I talked to Steve.
No,
no that's,
that's Steve Graham.
Steve Maxwell is the guy who teaches me kettle bells and comes over like a
couple of times a year and we,
you know,
he will go out size,
body issues.
He comes and trains me for like three days and shows me all sorts of new shit
and I film it on my uh,
my iPhone.
He's a master dude.
He's Steve Maxwell.
You can follow him on Twitter.
I don't know.
I think its maximal strength and conditioning.
Maxwell,
SNC,
Matt Maxwell,
SC maybe.
Um,
but he's a,
a real master when it comes to training and different things that you can do to,
uh,
to keep your body healthy as you get young.
Like he has a whole series,
a DVD series all on joint mobility and how important it is to stretch as you get
older.
Your range of motion,
especially if you're not,
like if you're just sitting in an office,
your range of motion is going to get more and more limited because you're not
doing shit.
Your body's not going anywhere.
You're just sitting there.
I was able to use those,
those yoga guys that can stretch like crazy.
They always like shocked me.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
And it's,
it's because they keep doing it.
It's because,
you know,
I mean most of the reasons why I'm still flexible at this age is because when I
was 15 to the time I was 44,
I never stopped stretching.
You just keep doing it.
If you keep doing it,
you can keep it up.
But if,
if you take off just like a few months,
you'd take off just a few months of training and don't work out and don't do
shit for a few months,
your body will turn to a sack of shit like that.
Do you feel that when you've,
when he stopped,
but he just kept trying and kept working out.
Dude,
I've never stopped.
Even when I get injured I'll,
I'll stop doing certain things.
Like I've been places where they say you can't do any working out.
Like after I got my nose fixed,
I couldn't do anything for a full month.
They said,
yeah,
they don't want to,
you're elevating your temperature or your,
uh,
blood pressure rather.
And possibly,
you know,
opening up,
some of the sutures are in,
so no exercise at all for four weeks.
So for four weeks I was like,
fuck,
there's just eat pizza and commit to it.
No,
I just,
I just try to eat healthy,
but I couldn't do shit.
And,
and in hopes that a,
I want,
I didn't want this operation to be fucked up cause I was without a nose to
breathe out of for most of my life.
And I knew how terrible it was.
But then once I did it,
I was like,
that was a race to get back in shape.
Terrified.
Because as you get older,
man,
the,
the morning show is lethal.
You just stay there.
Yeah.
You can just become a lazy fuck.
What,
what you gotta do this?
Cut this festival next year.
Which festival?
Moontower Moontower Austin one.
Did you just get back from that?
Yeah.
What was it?
Everybody's going to festival mail.
Did they pay you or did they uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
We're going to have a desk.
Quite festival.
We should,
that's quite fast.
Is gonna have music like honey honey asked them if they went to calm me.
We have some ever where,
where should we do this?
Uh,
I think fucking Joshua Tree.
Really?
But then he's going to go out there.
No,
no,
no.
In a city.
Yeah.
Why did,
why did they have to go somewhere?
Vegas.
Vegas isn't a bad idea.
Vegas is not a bad idea.
The Vegas again costs money,
man.
You got flying in and shit.
Tax is just do it for locals.
Austin,
Texas,
Texas might not be a bad idea somewhere where it's warm.
That's all that's in Texas is in the middle too,
so a lot of people can fucking drive there or fly there are a lot easier and
said,
well if we were going to have it,
we would want to have it at a place where there would be enough hotel rooms.
It was how many people are going to come?
You see?
Let's say if we have like putting New York do a comedy show,
they're
so expensive.
Looked at southwest by southwest,
we do it in the same area.
All those hotels had Austin right that south by southwest.
Yeah.
Maybe we could do it six months after when south by southwest was there.
So we don't compete with them at all.
And I'm Boston desk squad festival.
When is south by southwest or a month ago.
A month ago.
So it's a what?
April.
What do you worry about competing with south by Southwest Damien?
The first of all,
you can't do it anywhere near them because first of all,
they're way more established.
They're going to eat up all the hotel rooms.
I mean if you really wanted to do,
but then you would have to like organize it man,
and then you'd have to pay the bands.
Like if you have bands performing that,
yeah,
you get to hire a tour manager.
We'd have to figure out who would be,
I mean,
if we're going to have a desk squad comedy festival,
we'd have to be really picky about who we let go on stage too.
You know they're going to die.
They're going to represent us.
If it's three days,
we just use all the same guys who always use,
but there's like,
we have like 30 people that we use all the time and you just in different
rotations and stuff,
we made it a big festival and people got to plan for it.
They would want to do this,
you know,
it'd be about 30 people.
We don't have 30 people that are good enough to represent us.
You start grabbing neck,
telling him like,
hey,
like could they be Stephen is easy's and all the Freddy Lockharts and he'd be
like,
Hey,
do you want to calm 30 though?
I don't think it's 30 I'm sorry.
What do you think per,
I mean,
who are you talking about?
We're talking about little Esther,
you know we're talking about like the all,
all the guys and then you might even find that if it's a big enough thing that
like there's just people that want to hang out for a weekend,
like a party style.
And so you might get like maybe like Greg Fitzsimmons would be like,
hey,
I want to come to this,
you know,
and shit like that.
Maybe he would,
he would want to get paid and as he should.
Absolutely.
We'll make it fun.
Make it like a festival.
But then what?
You had different shots so they could see different people twice.
Yeah,
I guess they would have to,
if they went to different shows it would.
It would have to be some people on certain shows and the god,
it sounds like a lot of work,
but it'd be kind of fun.
Maybe something we could think of,
you know?
I mean,
look,
if the fucking insane clown posse can pull up my
daughter off,
we could pull it up.
Death squads shows at a comedy festival,
you know,
the really,
the best way to do it really would be to make it super simple and started off
simple and as easy as possible.
Try it out one year and then let it build,
you know?
Then the next year moving to Vegas,
we try and and Pasadena one year,
maybe we try it this year in passing away.
That's what you do here when another car,
you don't have to pay for hotels for almost any comic.
How about that?
How about we do it ice house,
continual ice house shows and we'll have like bands go up and perform at the ice
house.
We'll have two shows going on at the same time with the ice house and just take
over the club for like a whole week and have all of our friends come in and
vote.
It's so hard.
[inaudible] the fuck out of it.
Have all of our friends come in that we,
you know,
all of our friends like from out of town that we know that our great comics that
maybe live in be here.
Yeah.
Planning to be here.
I'm bringing Stan hope and pay for him and you know,
and,
and it put them up in a hotel and give them the door 100% of the door and just
and pumped the show up and,
and set it up.
So it's both profitable for guys to be and it looks like it's fun.
And the whole time we'd broadcast,
you know,
whatever the type of door we want to have two things set at one we're going to,
we want to have set up something.
So in the podcast room,
at the Ice House,
we can see the stage.
That's step one.
Step two is we're going to broadcast to podcast.
All the people waiting in line.
So while the people were waiting in line as they're going and we'll be doing the
podcast with speakers outside of that little courtyard area.
So that will be going on and then we'll have shows,
we'll have bands that can go up.
I love it that they made,
they made the bar room of Lovitz it should pull down a screen and they show
what's going on on that big screen on stage.
That's not a bad show.
The podcast or you can drink and just the bar area where we,
where would you do that outside there?
I mean the uh,
ice house again,
you can do it outside and that little bit of new area.
Yeah.
To everybody would go to smoke anywhere.
Sure.
Why not put a big screen up there,
right.
Like you could talk to like that one,
that whole property because that whole building that is owned by the same person
that owns like that parking lot that's right.
Connected to it.
And if we were to like close that off and then make it like,
you know,
different states upsides,
summer podcast,
broadcast the podcast to the parking lot and just have pulled up your own
chairs.
You need certain permits to do that though cause you could disturb other
businesses and you'll disturb the neighborhood.
Had that permission with all those businesses.
I don't think you could do that.
I don't think.
I think you know that first of all that's always in the park.
Tentative license.
Yeah.
But that's a movie and it's in a park.
This isn't a part,
it's a parking lot and it's right next to people's businesses.
Either would hear it for sure if honey honey is out there jamming carry like a
live band.
There's a festival that's in Columbus,
Ohio.
It's the whole weekend called calm fast co what it is,
it's community festival where everybody in the community gets together and
volunteers time work and making a festival.
So like a lot of my friends would like sit there and be,
you know the people that sell beer all day and they just do it for free.
And it's just,
there's three different stages for different stages and it's just music and,
and in
poetry and there's girls walking around naked and uh,
and it's,
and it's just people go there with tents and like pretty much just hang out at
this park the whole weekend.
And,
and it was just like,
imagine if it was something like that where,
cause like your fan base is so like,
uh,
like that kind of like outdoorsy mushrooms,
nature kind of,
you know,
they like music and Jimmy Hendrickson,
we could eventually do it someplace like that someplace cool.
But we would have to make sure that there's enough combinations for all the
people that were invited to come down.
Right.
You know,
it would be tricky and we would also have to make sure that we could safely get
all the artists there and put up,
put them up and places.
That's why starting an off in Pasadena,
it would be super easy because everyone's local.
We could have all the local guys go off and people that want to come here,
they can come here.
It's easy to get to Pasadena.
You can come here from all over the country.
We can set up a 10 at comm fest this year.
What's confessed?
That festival.
I was just telling him that.
Yeah,
I don't have a comedy team.
I don't think we need to bring in people like that.
I think.
I think we advertise to our own people.
We advertise to everybody who follows me on Twitter and everybody who follows me
on Facebook pod lead up time.
Yeah,
this is the week you're gonna want to make your hotel reservations.
Before I do that,
we could do that now and get thousands of people to come from all over the
country.
I have no idea.
There's a bunch of shows throughout the week leaving that two shows a night.
Pretty much to say the,
if you do doing a couple of locations lighthouse on somewhere else,
the ice house is a great place because it's,
look,
it's close to lax and people can get there.
They can get rental cars,
they can stay.
It's not a far drive.
You've got an navigation system.
It's not hard to swing,
you know,
it's,
it's totally feasible.
And we have the best relationship with that club,
the,
you know,
as far as clubs around,
and there's two rooms there,
so we could have two rooms running simultaneously and just keep doing shows.
We could do like two and three shows at night.
Like we could have an early show,
we can have a bunch of different shit going on or having music side stage.
Just how many times mad security for nutty people.
So many nutty people that been showing up at the icehouse Layla.
Oh,
I had a girl starts screaming out to it,
loves move during my show on the horror.
Did you just run up and shove it in her mouth?
How much do you love me?
But that's why.
So I can talk.
It was crazy.
And I was like,
what's wrong with you?
You're going to be quiet.
So what happened after the show?
You're hanging out with her?
No,
I told her shut to leave eventually.
I was like,
I understand that she was weird or something was on something she was on.
I love Ari.
I want some Judic.
Well stop just there by herself.
Well,
how did it end?
I told her she,
I believe she was there by herself there by they self is,
I'm really sorry.
Good sign of crazy.
Not always.
A lot of people come by themselves that are very nice,
but occasionally it's a sign of crazy.
Sometimes you going anywhere by herself.
It's like,
what?
What are you going to be up to right now?
Not always.
You know,
it could could mean you're cool.
I met some really cool people that came to shows by themselves.
Nothing wrong with it.
It's not like a hard fast rule rogue fest.
But if you meet a girl though and she comes to a show by herself that girls are
freak almost.
I'm by myself just hanging out
half.
So we would have to call this a the desk squad festival or something like that
to first we'd have to figure out what to call it.
Like the insane clown posse.
They call their shit.
The gathering of the Juggalos.
We would not call it the gathering of the Juggalos.
No,
we couldn't call it that.
They already have that damn it.
That would be so good for in order to get people to come out.
But death squad is going to give people the wrong impression.
Oh yeah.
Maybe we need to come up with a name for the festival,
like a yearly name.
Just call it all of garden.
Maybe the happy primate festival.
Most of all happy primary comedy,
but it's not,
it's not quite a comedy festival bands too.
Oh,
and we would just get,
just like primates do,
you'll get like some music club and Pasadena to show those shows.
Now.
We would do those at the ice house to put it put us.
There'll be easy to put up.
Like if a honey honey,
they could play at the,
um,
at the icehouse easy.
I'm sure they've had bands playing that place.
I have a jumped off the stage.
Yeah.
There's not much room.
I don't know how they would do that.
How much room is there?
Do you think there's room for a drum set?
No,
not on the stage.
Absolutely not.
No Way.
No.
Absolutely not.
There would be take up the entire state drums though.
There's some of their best things they do is just him and her,
him playing guitar and her playing Banjo Acoustic set.
Yeah.
That's better.
Anyway man,
the Acoustic Shit they did on my podcast was brilliant.
They don't do like 15 to 20 minutes at the end of 30 minutes or 40.
She's not like she,
she has a real voice man.
That chick has a real voice.
Like that's,
that's a legitimate voice.
So it's not like she doesn't need any effects or any fakery she really can sing.
I would do a storyteller show,
get crushed on dos to deal with.
Yeah,
we can do that too.
That could be a part of it.
Absolutely.
It's a good idea.
Yeah.
Just different themes or different shortage situations for like that.
And you know what,
we should also
ask topics.
That's exactly what I was going to say.
Question in that answer.
We should do a,
uh,
an entire show.
Like we did a little bit of it at the end of the show in Atlanta,
but it was more like mocking people for the stupid questions.
And more moon landing hoax,
conspiracy talk.
I want to hear it from his own mouth.
This guy goes,
well,
I do know that we went to the moon.
I love just saying that.
Well,
I do know.
I'm just saying it louder.
What does that mean?
Silly 1969 you know what happened?
No matter what the argument?
Well,
I just know.
Yeah,
so you're just hanging out.
Just on talking about.
No one knows.
I mean we can kind of assume most likely that happened.
I'm pretty sure Kennedy got shot in the head.
I'm,
I'm 99% positive,
but I wouldn't even say I'm 100% positive with that.
Fuck knows.
There's God damn dark world.
We live.
We'll take that argument too far.
Sometimes they're like,
well,
how did you even know there was a Kennedy world's real?
How do we not know that you are not living in a commune or something?
By the way,
I thought that was really hilarious.
I saw a video of you explaining to people how to download the bone zone and you
did it.
I sent a handicapped person as a person because I don't know how to do it.
One Brendan Walsh was complaining that people,
we're having a hard time finding his podcast.
It's pretty much,
I showed Brennan how to do it and he made a big deal about it on another podcast
and it's like,
ah,
come on here.
Let me do it real slow again for you
to show people how to,
how to,
how to download?
Yeah,
or just,
well,
I think he wants it to be under his name.
Is that what it is now?
He's just,
look,
people see that the kids search bone zone and it comes up on iTunes and so I was
like,
well,
let me show you how to do it,
but you can't show the people.
It's the people searching.
That's what you have to commit.
It's not pregnant.
How many people that are in your little network get upset that you have the
network as the name of their show and then they're shown next instead of the way
everybody else has to think out of.
Let's say
if there was a 100,000 people,
I think I hear it maybe two times on Twitter.
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about the people,
the people that host their shows.
How many of them want to change it to their own name?
It must all of them.
No,
I don't think so.
No.
I would say none of them now.
Right now.
Come on.
Brennan was,
doesn't want it to be in his name and then have you as the network second.
Yeah.
No,
I mean they look what happened with Freddie Lockhart and Freddy Lockhart did it.
He,
you know,
he got lost and so he came back.
No,
no,
no.
First,
first of all,
Freddy didn't.
He left you.
He stopped doing it and when he left it wasn't that he was,
you know that he went under his name and that's why people couldn't find him.
It's like he really,
nobody gave a shit about it.
Anyway,
you said you were going to find a way how people,
no,
no.
It has a color to all podcasts now that know Freddie left because he wanted to
do it on his own.
And then when I'm saying is that when he did that and then we could find his
podcast anymore because no one was listening to anymore because that's the only
because Freddie had not and he said,
dude,
not publicized it.
Well he didn't do a good job.
We talked about it on this part going on podcasts,
we tweeted it,
I even retweeted him tons of times.
No it is,
it is an extra step if people,
you consider the numbers of people that are listening to yours but in order for
him to have it go off on his own,
think about that.
He was doing yours for so long and it's still hadn't developed a name where he
could have his phone number one
podcasts on desk.
Why when it left and it went to 170
but you know,
so you understand what I'm saying?
Know what I'm saying?
Is he in the all the time he's doing it with you still hadn't gotten
independent.
He was still attached to your name.
So it's almost like he wasted time doing a good podcast under your name and
never got his name out there.
So when his name got out there on its own,
it flopped because no one knew about it.
He had been doing all this,
all this podcasting and spending all this time developing this,
this sort of a a bunch of fans to follow him and he couldn't take it with them.
Whereas if he just did it on his own,
whatever he built up would have been his own.
It would have stuck with them.
[inaudible] do you not make sense?
Yeah.
Do you know how many podcasts that there's comics out there that you've never
heard of in your life?
Did you know Mark Ellis had two podcasts?
Well,
yeah.
Well Mark Ellis is not a famous comedian.
You know,
Freddy Lockhart,
first of all was on a television show and he's been on our podcast many,
many times.
And you know Mark Ellis the most would be nice if people could search for his
name.
Yeah,
well they can,
they can search for his name.
The real thing is like the question is,
do you do it the way Adam Carolla does it,
where he has,
you know,
like someone's whatever,
the like Penn Sunday school and then underneath that it says ace broadcasting.
Oh,
so he has it in a secondary position and he's allows the,
the person's name of their podcast that's first and he's just the production arm
of it.
You can build up on it.
Whereas Brian,
the way Brian does it is he has a channel and you know,
it's the desk squad channel and then everybody else's podcast is sort of
secondary to that.
It's actually the exact opposite.
It's collecting.
It all builds up the network.
It builds up the network as a whole instead of building up each individual as an
entity on their own.
Everyone helps each other.
If you're a big Sam Aaa fan,
you start listening to Sam triple,
you're going to start listening to Brendon Walsh,
vice versa.
There's so many people that never knew who Brennan Walsh was until they just
were like,
well,
I like Freddy Lockhart.
I'm going to start listening to Brendon Walsh now because they're on the same
network and vice
verse.
So that's also the case of what people came onto this podcast.
Yeah,
but that's not the same reason that there would be people who were like,
oh,
I don't like,
let's just say,
I mean,
here's an example.
Pockets,
they get annoyed and don't listen to the same AAA.
Pacos here's an example.
It turned off by this stuff they're not into and they're like,
how much of this do I have to sit through it before?
Don't do it.
Don't listen to it.
Do you have to listen to every single wine?
No.
It'd be just less lucky to see it.
Why you?
Let's look at the,
see it,
the six things that are there and you only need to one of them.
It's just like you're less likely to check in and see when there's updates.
Well,
my,
my only thought is that someone is going to make sense of their own shit on
their own.
If they're doing their own show on their own and they they brand,
I mean they start like Doug loves movies,
started out on his own captain on zone and at this point in time we a lot of
shows that equity that he's built up in that name and doing on on his own.
And for a lot of these other guys,
they're building equity into the desk squad name and it's not,
it's not transplant to
look at Ari superior,
look at Thompson Sigora.
There's ways that you can do it right?
They were,
they were lucky people like their show and they're listening to it.
Aria is doing good on his podcast and so is Tom Segura.
So what are you trying to say?
I'm just saying right at the end I left.
I know,
that's what I'm saying.
I'm just saying that,
that I don't think that like it works for everyone.
I think.
And I think that like,
like I think of Sam Aaa wanted to like move off a death squad.
He can totally do it and he would probably survive.
But like,
I don't think that it's,
it'd be nice if there's a way to stay on dust squad,
but also have their own picture for their podcast or something.
Yeah,
they are pictures.
That's all.
I'll tell you what we're talking.
What reason why?
I mean you,
you actually made a bad example because the reason why Ari and Dunkin,
well Dunkin especially did it completely independently on his own,
but what got them,
what got them famous was being on a podcast that was famous.
This one.
That's what got him,
that's 100% with not being on the desk while they were like,
how many of your listeners already do you think are not a,
uh,
of Joe Rogan?
I was like,
oh,
maybe like 1% maybe 2%.
Yeah.
So a lot of people
found me.
I don't mind it,
which is fine.
You know,
look,
we're all sort of different,
but likeminded folks will apologize it.
Like they're like,
I didn't mean,
I'm sorry,
I didn't even know you do to stand up.
I didn't want to even see you.
But before I hear it in the podcast,
I'm like,
I don't care.
That means you're here because of that.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
The biggest thing I wanted to stress though is the reason why it's done as a
group is is is also looking past what podcasts like.
I don't really think that power through numbers that in 20 years podcasts are
going to be fucking kicking ass or anything,
but one thing I do know that's coming up is the the the basic future of cable
television and networks and stuff or go into more of a streaming base,
a download based system like Netflix or iTunes that that is true.
Like there's not going to be an NBC and tenure independently of whether or not
you made your show the first name or their show.
The first name when he was,
what I was saying is death squad.
Dot.
TV to me is like,
I'm kind of considering it more like a,
Eh,
this is a channel.
This is more than just just you're listening to a podcast that your house,
this is like a TV show network where each one of these shows are like a,
it's like being on death squad is like dot.
TV,
but it's like being on like MTV and each one of these things underneath it as a
show.
And so one of the biggest things with like all the people saying,
you know,
like I want it to be separated into all the different things on iTunes and all
that,
all that stuff.
If you don't want to just go to [inaudible] dot TV and download what you want to
listen to.
We're making the show pages right now where like as an example,
if you like the uh,
naughty show,
it's going to have all the,
the,
the naughty shows.
I was going to have an RSS feed,
which you can do right now.
And in any browser,
if you open up your browser,
pick a search string of any kind,
you can make an RSS feed.
Stop it.
No one's doing that.
No one's making RSL anyways.
I'm just saying that you can't,
you can do it if you're,
if you're freaking out about RSS feeds,
you probably know can easily cut and paste an RSS string.
Well,
when people don't know,
no one's food is freaking out about RSS feeds.
Exactly the 1%.
So anyways,
but each one of these,
each one of these pages,
uh,
like,
like the naughty show page and stuff like that,
we'll have all the individual,
uh,
shows for each person and it's going to have,
each host is going to have a paypal,
uh,
show donation.
How many of your network shows or you actually in every single one and every one
of them.
So that's another thing that's,
that's I produced them all.
The only ones I don't do is when like,
like I say,
Brian Count or somebody is doing one in their hotel room.
Doesn't that drive you crazy to be in all those different podcasts?
I mean,
your brain must be scattered now because it's,
it's quality control for everything.
I mean there's like,
there's like,
there's like shows like I love Esther to death,
but you know,
if,
uh,
if I didn't,
if I wasn't there and just put it up,
I would be mad at myself for fucking letting you listen to it.
And,
and vice versa.
Sometimes,
you know,
there's,
there's a quality that all these people get where like,
you know,
when,
when Ari was on,
uh,
on death squad,
he,
you sent me one file once and it was like one person was really loud,
one person was super,
super quiet.
You can hear it.
And I know Ari was angry
at me for not wanting to put that up exactly what you were saying.
We're not putting it up before you let me listen to it.
That's all it was.
It was like,
let me hear it.
I'll make my decision.
Right.
But it kept saying no,
and I told him I couldn't put it up because honestly,
I sat there for two hours trying to fix it,
to make it so it would be acceptable and it wasn't.
And that totally makes sense because a lot of people don't know that,
that,
yeah,
I'm on these pockets cause I'm fucking producing them.
I told,
I told uh,
um column cause after you told him I like his stuff was the same way.
It wasn't coming through.
I was like,
do you know you have to get microphones in courts without right?
And he goes,
no,
I didn't know that.
I was like,
yeah,
you got to get my coupons in chords.
So he got told them where to get it.
Yeah.
I like those way better from now on.
The only problem that I have is that we use the name death squad for all of us.
And if you got a network that's death squad and then anyone who is on there
because it's one of those people and not necessarily the real death squad way to
do it is to do Joey's podcasts podcast,
to put it on a page somewhere.
We could put that if you,
if you,
if Brian one too offensive right now,
no one's saying anything bad because that makes no sense.
No,
it makes a lot of sense.
What I'm saying?
I do a display.
It's a 100% clear on what you're doing,
like it's being attacked and people on,
and I think you're doing the same thing because,
because what it is is I'm doing the same thing.
What?
Because what I'm doing is you're,
you're pretty much saying the real reason to do a podcast network like,
like I'm not doing a real reason,
a way to do it just because I'm using the words I'm saying.
The right way to call it desk won.
It should not just be the shows that you're in.
It should be all of us.
It desk squad is a bunch of friends,
right?
All these people that we have,
I'm doing all these shows.
I've been on the road with you,
Sam.
Aaa has been on the road with you.
Right?
Stop it.
You're not killing people that have been on the road with Pamela loss.
Not what you're doing.
You're,
you've got a bunch of pillows.
Even know who these people are talking about.
The host of the show up right in a while.
She used to take some else on the right,
right.
Some of them bring you want to consider and being in the death squad,
Brian?
Some of them,
some of them,
some of them not.
You know,
come on all that shit.
There's a bunch of them.
I don't want to name names.
I don't want to criticize anybody I know,
but every person is a guest on the show.
I wouldn't consider it beyond a desk squad would you
like if you have a person that's on your show as a guest,
there's a big difference.
She didn't happen to someone on its guest is how it's someone who you're doing a
show with them and then you're calling it desk squat and you're putting it on a
network.
You essentially have taken over that name and use it for your own stuff.
It's just squad.
I'm not desk squad.
You're on everyone that does squad.
All of us are a desk while you were on every one of them because I produce every
single show on that.
That's why.
Yes,
but do you not see that that is like that is like you are sort of 90% of the
shows like I probably talk about 10% of the time.
It's usually,
it's more of a same thing.
If he listened to Howard Stern,
if he listened to any of the shows that have producers like Iraq or anything
like that,
that's a normal thing,
Joe.
Dude,
I'm not saying there's anything wrong with what you're doing.
I'm not saying that at all.
I'm not criticizing you.
I'm just saying that to call it to death squad is kind of weird because the
desk,
what it's supposed to be,
all of us,
and most of the people that are in the dusk squad aren't on the desk.
Squad.
Dot.
T so
if one of you other guys did something with a desktop game,
then go for it.
I was the first one.
I was like,
Hey,
I'm just going to make a collection of shows and call it death squad cars.
Obese said at one time,
and it was funny.
Yeah,
but it's not the that you don't do,
you know?
Well you be death squads a little different to you,
like you feel it's like the four people that was in the room.
I do not.
I feel it's family.
It's all the people that were family and I think it's a lot of people that you
podcasts,
whether you,
they asked me,
we're going to do this.
Hold on girls.
Nice.
And Brian Keeley,
she's a very nice girl.
Dan Dumas and very nice girl.
Those people aren't your family.
Uh,
we were shown up.
They're friends of mine that can meet their friends with you.
She's a nice girl.
She's not my federal on this podcast I have,
what does the question,
Brian,
just to put a lot of people we've had on this podcast,
but you're acting like a tree house and you're like,
you're not allowed in this tree house.
That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying you're calling it desk.
Why?
When death squad is us desk was us as friends,
you know,
tagging all the people that were hanging out together.
And that group,
there was no,
there was not the whole desk.
It'll be called us desk squad.
So you're saying Joe d is this because this is,
Joey does not.
One of my best friends is Joey Diaz.
Not Constantly on the road with us when we w is Joey d is not the one who uses
it more than anybody.
He was the one who actually started calling.
Everybody does squad.
He's the one who ran with it.
He thought it was hilarious.
There's obviously some heat here then because you were really having a problem
with me using the name.
Not even a problem at all.
All had a radio station at night and we were all talking about and I just
happened to start calling something desk squad.
It doesn't mean that I'm like,
no,
he was talking about me and it's all me and I'm deaf squad and that's what I
mean.
I'm just saying that I used a term that we all use and I bought a domain and
started doing a podcast for you.
Started doing a podcast and started calling the show's death squad car gas
networks.
So you have essentially hijack the name,
uh,
taking the name for your own lightweight,
that name desk while you're taking it for your own network.
The net with a name.
Why not saying you aren't?
I'm just saying if it really was desk won,
you would have so sorry on that.
I have big links to all the people that you're not profiting from as well.
If I,
if I created a podcast network and called it powerful,
are you saying that that wasn't what would then be allowed to do that?
It's a big difference between a whole group of people that call themselves death
squad.
We've been calling ourselves death squad for like almost a decade,
and then all of a sudden a podcast comes along and you call this podcast that
domain 2007 does mean Brian,
what does that mean?
Just because you bought the domain,
didn't we call ourselves that before you bought the domain?
Yeah.
So we call ourselves a lot of things,
but that,
does that mean I'm not allowed to say,
hey,
I might use that as a name for a podcast,
that workout all you guys,
I can't even believe that you don't see another side of this.
I can't believe I see what you're saying,
but it's kind of funny that I've been doing it since 2007 and now you're just
making it so [inaudible] is that it just be all of us included,
the guys,
the guys that aren't in a podcast network don't profit from it,
and he's not saying you've done something specific.
Hold on.
Listen for a second.
Is that something you'd done?
Anything specifically wrong?
I know you knew I was gonna say that.
I was going to say that
Brian.
I know he's not saying you'd done anything specifically wrong.
He's saying,
wouldn't it be nice to have built a page or in the future to build a page to
include the people
in that group to begin with?
It should.
It should be all of us.
It should be Joey Diaz.
It should be Duncan.
It should be people that have never been in the pocket.
There we go right there.
Because,
because that who does this?
Who does that gets to choose to design it?
Because like you said some you might,
how about I'll choose.
Yeah,
but why?
Why?
Why shouldn't death squad?
I'll tell you this
because I'm going to treat it fairly.
How much?
Cause I'm gonna
tell me how I'm not.
Because there's somebody that you might want on there that I might not want on
there and there might be something on you don't think Dunkin deserves to be in
because you and him and having an argument,
you don't think the Dunkin deserves to be part of desk squad.
He's told me before.
But you were,
there were arguments at the bar when you were the argument cames from Dunkin
getting upset at Brian when we were in Atlanta was saying the Brian doesn't pay
the comedians when he charges money for the shows at the ice house and then it
should,
you should put it up.
But yeah,
I do.
And he just didn't know.
You only paid the MCS.
That's not true.
Okay.
I can draw it.
You should pay now or you're going to throw me under the bus too because you
have no idea anyway.
Right.
If you started paying people recently,
this is a different thing.
Don't turn off Bro.
You can't recapture this again because when you don't raise your voice and don't
get crazy,
first of all,
let me explain that John can shouldn't have done what he did.
He threw me under a bus.
Brian me drunk.
Even though I had a beer and a red bull is not an insult.
So he's also just fucking,
he wasn't correct.
He was trying to diminish,
he was trying to attack me on,
on.
All right.
So that's a hard thing was discussed.
The problem,
what I happened and what he was getting at is we were talking about southwest by
southwest,
right south by southwest.
He does this video that where it says that southwest by southwest makes a
shitload of money,
whatever it's called.
And they don't pay people to come out there cause he was offered to come out
there and he didn't get paid.
And so what I had brought up is that I had been hearing that really it's all
about the venues like southwest by southwest.
It's like a blanket name,
kind of like a death squad.
And it's into each of the venues that,
that,
that if they want you to come out and play their bar,
that they might pay you,
you know?
But southwest doesn't do anything to promote it as a big party,
you know,
like they,
they do advertising and promotions and stuff like that.
And then when I'm talking to Duncan made a video saying that they don't pay
anyone in and they steal from comics.
So what happened is I was talking to,
and I was explaining like,
Hey,
I heard this and he goes,
you're drunk.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
okay,
this is not your a really paraphrasing obviously obviously so,
so,
uh,
what then it turned into it that he's,
he said on a podcast you steal from comics.
And I was like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Cause you still from comedy,
you don't pay your comics.
And I'm like,
well,
Dunkin wine,
why do you,
why do you think I don't pay my comics?
I do pay,
uh,
the,
the MC or the host usually,
which is like Tony Hinchcliffe or will I give them 40 to 60 bucks and I then I
pay usually if there's any people like little Esther or anyone that I know that
it's like fucking,
you know,
like they don't even have gas money to get there.
I'll throw him 20 to 40 bucks sometimes.
And like as an example of this last one I gave,
you know,
little Esther money I gave Mark Ellis some cash.
I and I,
you know,
I spread it out.
I'll tell you,
those people have been grow more.
You've got to show that cash for people.
All right.
What do people,
I'm driving out there,
there's a cover charge home.
I'm not going to put it.
All right.
Well here's an example.
You don't want to say names.
People are pissed.
All right,
well here's,
here's a,
here's what,
a couple of reasons why.
One,
because I don't get paid till the following week.
So anything I pay for that night is I have to go to an ATM,
I have to take out money and have to fucking go,
all right,
how much money did I make this sell out?
Then the following week usually,
oh,
and so then,
so then I have to figure out how much money did I kind of make?
Did it sell out somewhere there?
The door,
look how much I could do that if I wasn't doing a live podcast at the same time.
But anyways,
uh,
and then I get tax and all of that.
So everything I make there,
which is not even the,
the,
the door,
I don't get the full door.
I get like 60% of the door or something like that.
Then I get taxed on it so that,
that pretty much cuts in half.
So what I'm,
what my average is usually is it's about $200 to $300 I make on a show.
I usually spend about a hundred dollars,
uh,
giving it to the miscellaneous comics to $150,
and the other hundred $50 to me is like,
okay,
now I could either not do the show or make $150 for booking a show,
advertising his show and producing the two bucks a ticket times.
And it's usually 15 when Joe does it and 10 when I do it.
But I give out so many free tickets and it's usually not one,
not one.
Joe Goes,
where do I give it out when Joe does it too?
You don't have to.
I don't have to usually,
but usually,
yeah,
but usually it's also give it away.
Free tickets.
Those are the common disorders.
I like the,
they split the main room,
just the one show,
but it's nice.
The main room,
half goes to the comedy store and half goes to the community.
Let me say something.
Here's how you avoid all this.
Don't actually do this.
That's what I want to do.
This is how you avoid all this forever.
Be infallibly generous,
be generous to the point where they can't infallibly do it to the point where
they can't argue against it.
The be generous to the point where you're not saying,
you know,
I,
I'm gonna make 150 bucks because I feel like I deserve it because what I do want
to do it,
you're right.
You know what that makes me want to do not do it at all.
I don't give a fuck cause that to me,
very,
very defensive stance.
And especially when you're talking to me,
and then the reason that people are going to the show is because I'm headlining
and I'm promoting it on my Twitter.
Obviously not a bad thing,
man.
You should make some money.
You should make,
you know what?
I don't,
I don't do it for money.
I don't want anything to do with the money.
But I also don't want to do anything like that for free because consider that
work because
then you're doing it for money.
If you don't want to do it for free,
then you doing it right.
You should not change then.
Okay,
man,
listen you,
you,
you're sounding like a little kid.
This is craziness because I'm not being mad at you at all.
Tagging on podcast,
we can,
no one hears attacking you,
Bro.
You,
you and I are friends.
We're like brothers.
Okay.
Always like a brother.
We're all here together.
We're trying to talk,
but you were like really triggers strung in.
One of the reasons is because you feel like they're attacking you for his choice
and you're trying to defend this choice.
What I'm saying is the only reason why they even can attack you is because there
is a point of view that they're expressing that may be seven south by southwest,
but their version is this like,
well,
it,
you should want to be here.
It's a really fun time and you're like,
Yo,
I didn't want to be there,
but it would also be nice to have the money you're collecting for the shows and
Austin would come to some of us who were going to shows.
I think there's good in having those shows there.
I think it's good for the comedy club.
I think it's good for that.
First of all,
the comedians should be getting paid directly to the comedy clubs.
So you don't have,
you could easily do that.
We should that.
That's honestly to me.
And that's good,
isn't it?
Have them take each of their trucks to me.
In the past,
honestly,
it was more like,
you know what?
This isn't how it should be,
but right now I'm too busy to fucking sit down,
renegotiate this thing that we started.
Okay,
well that's honest.
That's very honest of it.
And I never did not.
I've never not paid anyone on a show.
It meaning there was never a show where I didn't pay anybody.
Brian,
when you get really mad at something,
that's because people are right,
and it doesn't mean that you're a bad person.
It means they might have a point.
Not all of our actions.
The reason why I pissed off at this or were originally pissed off of me because
I first heard of that,
one of the first things I did was Dunkin did this and it did it on a live
podcast.
He blind side of me.
And while if you went to death squad.
Dot.
TV.
There was a huge fucking linkedin I did out of the own kindness of my heart.
He didn't ask me to talk to bias poster.
Okay,
hold on.
Do you have this argument to bring up something else?
You've done a nice for a person.
Well then somehow,
so how dare you bring up this a argument.
I might say a separate org,
three minutes,
but he's got a very good point.
The only thing,
and the reason I would say that is because in the past I've done a lot for this
guy and he,
and instead of just like talking to me and going,
hey,
why don't you do this or die?
And I could explained this whole thing I just did to you.
And He'd be like,
oh,
that kind of makes sense.
So let's just do it.
I'll slow down slow.
We have three minutes.
We have to end this.
So
no,
no.
Listen,
we're going to end this part.
We're going to come back and wrap this up because this is too ridiculous.
We'll have a little part one and a part two.
So let's stop this portion of it and we'll come back with a very informal five
minutes.
We'll take a little break,
but we need to,
we need to relax and calm us down cause this is,
this is really getting great.
That'll help elect to anything.
So let's pause it right now.
Let's thanked the flashlight.
Please go to Joe Rogan dotnet entering the code named Rogan and save yourself
15% off.
Number one sex toy for men.
And they are our first and original sponsor here at the Joe Rogan referrals
hall.
Thank you.
Also to onnit.com o n n I t.com.
Makers of Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom tech,
all that shit.
You know what it is?
Go check it out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com read up on this stuff is a first 30 pills.
There's always a 100% money back guarantee you as a kid.
Code name,
Rogan,
save yourself 10% we're gonna just take a little break and we'll be right back
with a very informal wrap up to this crazy conversation.